I COULD BE ABLE. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY.
AND TO PROTECT PUBLIC WILL JUST
POP LEDGER AN EMPLOYEE. WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IF YOU'RE A SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN FACE COVERING IT
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AT THE CAPITOL WITH
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. ARE
MEMBER AT TENDING REMOTELY
TODAY. IS THE ONE AND ONLY
SENATOR GLAZERS. CENTER GLAZER
IF YOU HAVE A STAFF PERSON-
WITH YOU CAN YOU IDENTIFY THAT
STAFFER NOW. THANK YOU CHAIR
DIED. I DON'T HAVE ANY STAFFER
IN MY OFFICE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
I CENTER GLAZERS REMINDER
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY YOU COULD
FEED I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WERE TO BE WRECKED THAT YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE OF THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU
WHEN YOU'RE DONE WHAT'S
RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIRES ALLOW. IT
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THAT'S ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO ZERO
EIGHT THREE SIX ONE SEVEN ZERO
ZERO EIGHT. THREE SIX ONE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. WITH
THIS COULD BE A REALLY SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE YOU DID ADD NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE.
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ODD PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
LET'S PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. BEFORE WE
HEAR THE PRESENTATIONS ON THE
BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
THERE'S NOT A PORN YET. WHO DO
WE HAVE IT'S COMING. WHO WERE
WE WERE. WELL GOOD NOT GREAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT MEMBERS. SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON HERE.
ARCHULETA. OKAY WE HADN'T DONE.
YEAH LITTLE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YEAH YOUR MIKE'S
NOT WORKING. DOT HERE. DOT HERE.
DOT HERE WILK PRESIDENT.
WELCOME PRESIDENT ALAN.
ARCHULETA CARE MUCH WHEN I HEAR
BARGES. I'M NOT A VOTERS
PRESIDENT BRADFORD EASIER AS
ALWAYS BRADFORD HERE CHIANG
HERE CHAD HERE BECAUSE THE ARMY.
GLAZER SAN GLAZERS PRESENT
SENATE GLAZER PRESENT HILL.
HILL HERE WESO. CHANCE JONES
HERE NIELSEN THERE NIELSEN HERE
PORTANTINO. RUBIO RUBIO
PRESIDENT WIENER. FINALLY HAVE
A QUORUM- WITH SURGERY NOTES
QUORUM IT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED I
WANT TO REMIND OUR MEMBERS
THAT- HE GOT TO GET THIS ON THE
RECORD SO YOU'VE GOT TO SPEAK
CLEARLY INTO THE MIKE ANYTIME
THAT YOU'RE BEING ASKED WHETHER
YOU'RE HERE. OR NOT OR ANY
COMMON TO. AND WE HAVE FOR. UP
TO ON TO AGENDA WE BE HEARING
BILL'S FILE ORDER BEGINNING
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WILL
BEGIN WITH THE CONSECUTIVELY
SAID THERE ARE EIGHT ITEMS ON
THE THIS CALENDAR. BUILDER FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY NINE FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE ELEVEN OH SEVEN. FILE
NUMBER ITEM SEVEN. AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTEEN FILE EIGHT. TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX FILE ITEM TEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY. FILE
ITEM TWELVE TB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY. THIRTY TWO SIX
SEVEN COULD MOST ON THE KIDS.
SIDEROXYLONWITH THE MOTION. UN
SECRETARY WE- PLEASE CALL. I IN
MEMBERS PLEASE WE ARE REMINDED
TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE THIS IS A CONSENT
ITEM DODD. ALL RIGHT. DOT HI
WILK HI WILK HI ALAN. ARCHULETA
BY. GOALIES BARGES HI VILLAGES
HI BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI CHIANG
HI JOHN HI GALGIANI. BARDIANI
ON GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS HI
SENATOR GLAZERS ANI HILL. HI
HILL I WANT SOME. JONES HI HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN FIVE
PORTANTINO. RUBIO RUBIO HI
WIENER. CHINA HAS ENOUGH THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PUT IN A CALL.
ALL HAS ENOUGH TO PASSED WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
OKAY LET'S NOW HERE- FROM OUR
FIRST OFFER A SENATOR GLAZERS
EXCUSE ME CENTER ARCHULETA
SKEWS ME. YOU'RE GOING TO BE
APPEARING HERE FOR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. GOOD MORNING
MR SENATORS AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY PERCENT- BILL
FIVE EIGHTEEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE EIGHTEEN IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW THE CITY
OF NORWALK EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS
UNTIL THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TO PURCHASE THE VACANT
SOUTHERN YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
RECEPTION CENTER AND CLINIC. AT
A FAIR MARKET VALUE AND IT IS
DETERMINED TO BE SURPLUS AS
STATE PROPERTY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
THIS SITE AND THE CITY OF
NORWALK. SET IN THE HEART OF
THE DISTRICT I'M PROUD TO SERVE
WITH THE AUTHOR WHO HAS BEEN AN
ENTHUSIASTIC PARTNERED MAKING
THIS LONG AWAITED BILL FINALLY
HAPPEN. THIS FACILITY. SAID.
THIS FACILITY SAID BACON ON
THIRTY TWO ACRES OF LAND FOR
MORE THAN EIGHT YEARS AND WAS
FORMERLY USED TO HUSE JUVENILE
OF. THE CITY OF NO WORK PLANS
TO REVITALIZE THIS PROPERTY
WITH MIXED USE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL FEATURE
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE HOUSING
UNITS FOUR HUNDRED OF WHICH
WILL BE RESERVED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND FIFTY SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND FEET OF
COMMERCIAL SPACE. GIVEN THAT
THIS FACILITY IS LOCATED LESS
THAN TWELVE HUNDRED FEET FROM
THE HEAVY UTILIZE NORWALK SANTA
FE SPRINGS METROLINK STATION. A
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
CAN HELP ALLEVIATE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY WITH RESIDENTS MORE
INCLINED ON USING THE NEARBY
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN IS IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE CITY OF
NORWALK WITH A TRANSIT ORIENTED
MIXED USE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT%
SITE AND DELIVER MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF DURING OUR ON GOING TO
HOUSING PRICES FOR AN ESTIMATED
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED RESIDENTS
AS- AS EARLY AS TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU FOR THE THANK
YOU FOR THE THREE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
AB OE ONE TO IN SUPPORT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. SIDEROXYLON I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE HIS SHOES GOMEZ CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF NORWALK
ON THE PHONE. THE DURING MY
YEARS CITY. OKAY A MISTER GOMEZ
PLEASE PROCEED. HERE MEMBERS OF
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE I FIRST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE NORWALK COMMUNITY
AND ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR AND
CITY COUNCIL I WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO TAKE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE'RE PREPARED TO BE
DEVELOPED THE- CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY PROPERTY WITH A
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITY THAT
WOULD BE A BENEFICIAL WE CRY OR
THE AREA. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH YOU GOVERNOR STATE IN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL STAFF.
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE THAT
PARTNERSHIP TO. REDEVELOP THE
PROPERTY INTO A YEAR AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT CAN BE DONE WITHOUT
PROPERTY SUCH AS- THIS ONE
HERE. AND AS MENTIONED WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT.
AND BY EIGHT OUR COMMUNITY WITH
THE EXTRA ORDINARY OF
REDEVELOPMENT A PROJECT THAT
WOULD DROUGHT FACILITY FOR
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GOMEZ NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO- ARE
THERE ANY- WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEEING NONE. WELL
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE. MMHM THE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE ONE EIGHT.
WE WILL BEGIN. WHERE TO START
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE NOT
ENTERED OKAY- CAN WE ASK ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. I'D BE GLAD
TO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO INSURANCE
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME SIR. OKAY
SO NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM EIGHTY
OPPOSITION- LET'S MOVE THE
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING THAT. WILL MOVE THROUGH
OUR- WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE. AND NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOR ONE EIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN SHOW
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE ONE
EIGHTY MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR
EIGHTY FIVE ONE EIGHT. AND I
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
FOR EIGHTY FIVE ONE EIGHT OR
PLEASE CONTINUE WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVING CALL THAT LINE
TWICE AS WELL. WE WILL NOW.
BRING IT BACK TO DISCUSSION-
FROM THE MEMBERS OF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. US
ASSEMBLY PACIFIC SEVERAL JOBS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I FIVE I
THINK THAT THE IDEA AND THE
CONCEPT OF THE BILL IS
FANTASTIC I BELIEVE THAT- THE
STATE OUGHT TO IDENTIFY AS MUCH
SURPLUS PROPERTY IS IT CAN AND-
AND PUT ON THE MARKET TO MAKE
AVAILABLE FOR- WHATEVER PROJECT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THINK
IS APPROPRIATE I'M EXCITED
ABOUT. THIS LOCAL CITY- AND
THIS PROJECT THERE'S JUST ONE
SMALL. A BIG PART OF THE BILL
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC IN THAT
ALLOWS THE STATE TO SELL THIS
PIECE OF PROPERTY BELOW FAIR
MARKET VALUE- THAT'S A CONCERN
FOR ME THIS PIECE OF PROPERTY
THAT BELONGS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE ASSET BELONGS TO
ALL OF THE TAXPAYERS OF THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
I THINK WE HAVE A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES TO GET THE HIGHEST
VALUE IN THE HIGHEST RETURN FOR
THE TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA
HAND SO UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I DO
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT AND THE
IDEA AND- HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
MORE- CONCEPTS LIKE THIS GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK CENTER
AND I ON. IF IT'S A FUNCTION
COMES IF THAT ELEMENT OF THE
BILL COMES I WILL. BE WILLING
TO SUPPORT IT ON THE FLOOR.
THAT ARE HUESO. YOU KNOW JUST
IN RESPONSE AND. I'M I'VE
LOOKING AT THIS BILL GENERALLY
WONDERING WHY THEREARE NONE
OTHER ASSETS INCLUDED I HAVE
ONE OF MY DISTRICT THAT I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO. DEAL WITH THAT.
ONLY BE IS A LIABILITY WHERE WE
ACTUALLY PUT IT FOR SALE.
NOBODY BID. AND IT'S- THE
REASON IS IT'S IN A NATIONAL
GUARD ARMORY. THAT'S BETWEEN
INCRETIN MIDDLE HIGH SCHOOL.
AND SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO BUY
THIS YEAR COULD SOMEHOW. THE
ONLY HAVE THE INSTITUTIONAL
ZONING. AND SO- LOOKING TO
DEVELOP THEIR- AND SEVEN TRYING
ALSO DISCLOSED DISPOSE OF THIS
AS PROPERTY OF MY DISTRICT AND
I CAN'T. FIND A USE FOR IT- THE
SCHOOL IS WILLING TO TAKE. IT
OVER AND USE IT TO ENHANCE FEEL.
AND THE RED. AND THEY'RE
WILLING TO PUT SOME MONEY THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY IT BUT IT'S
A VERY DEPRESSED. I KNOW IT'S
ON NOT ON THE SUBJECT FISH
RELATED MR SHERIFF OF JUST YOU
YOU KNOW. ONE SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT I WANT TO LOOK AT. ALSO
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN OF A
LOOK AT OTHER SITES AT THE- TO.
THE STATE HAS TRIED TO. DISPOSE
OF IN A WAY THAT IS GOOD FOR
THE TAXPAYERS. THIS PROPERTY IS
ONLY BEEN GOING UP. IN COSTS TO
THE STATE. IT USED TO BE SIXTY
THOUSAND. NOW IT'S A HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEXT YEAR PROBABLY A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND IN TERMS
OF LIABILITY TO THE RATEPAYERS
IT THEY GRAFFITI IT- THERE WAS
A THEY THEY BREAK CAN THE THIRD
THEIR WEEDS GROWING UP THE KIDS
IN THE SCHOOL HAVE TO ORGANIZE-
EVENTS TO REMOVE RETWEET TO
REMOVE TRASH AND PAINTED OVER.
AND IT'S THESE- IT'S IT I GUESS
IT'S A COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROJECT FOR THE KIDS OF THE
SCHOOL BUT- IT'S A IT'S A
BLIGHT ON THE SCHOOL AND I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT IS KIND OF
THE- AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE STORY IS THAT
WE SHOULD REALLY LOOK AT
PROPERTIES ARE OPPOSING A PLAN
HAZARD ON COMMUNITIES LIKE.
THIS ONE PROBABLY IS AND I'LL
CONTINUE TO. YOU KNOW ASK OF
MAYBE THE AUTHOR IF HE KNOWS.
HOW MUCH OF A- HAZARDOUS IS TO
THE COMMUNITY IF ANYTHING AT
ALL. THE BILL HAD CENTER
ARCHULETA CUTE IN IN RESPONSE
TO- CENTER JONES AND REGARDING
THE SALE BELOW MARKET. THIS IS
ONLY PERMITTED IF DEAN IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE. AND
DISCOUNTED SALE PRICE TO
DETERMINE TO AID IN THE
DEVELOPMENT ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO IT'S NOT
A BLANKET IT'S GOT TO BE
REANALYZED MAKE SURE CANCER
THIS IS WHY I'M I'M HOPING
YOU'LL YOU'LL MAKE THAT
ADJUSTMENT- AND THE SITE IS- AS
I MENTIONED IT IS IN MY
DISTRICT. AND THE SITE IS VERY
NEAR THE TRANSIT THE PROPOSED
TRANSIT AREA SHOPPING FREEWAYS
EVERYTHING ELSE SO IT'S A GREAT
AREA THE CITY OF NORWALK. IS
READY TO POUR IN THEIR PORTION
OF THE MONEY TO DEVELOP FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO BRING
IN THE COMMERCIAL THAT'S NEEDED
AS WELL. SO IT IS THERE AND AS
I MENTIONED IT'S BEEN A BAND.
FOR GOOD EIGHT YEARS. SO IT IS
SOMETHING THAT. US MEMBER
CALDERON AND I'VE WORKED
TOGETHER ON TO MAKE THIS THING
FINALLY HAPPENED. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A FANTASTIC CLOSE COULD
HAVE A MOTION ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION SPEECH MAY NEED TO
CUT OFF- CENTER RUBIO. AM I ON.
I WANT TO ALSO PEAK TO IT I
KNOW THE AREA VERY WELL AND
IT'S I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE CITY OF
NORWALK AND DIE WITH HOUSING
BEING SUCH A- DEFICIENCY THESE
DAYS I THINK IT'SAN
APPROPRIATE USE. IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE OF HOUSING AND I KNOW
THAT LIKE I SAID IT'S A
NEIGHBORING CITY AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY SO I ALSO
WITH SUPPORT THAT CAN KILL.
THAT THE EMOTIONS THAT ARE
RUBIO. IT'S BEEN MADE BY
SENATOR RUBIO. I DON'T SEE ANY-
CENTER PORTANTINO YES JUST A
BRIEF COMMENT- AS I'VE BEEN
SAYING IT ALL OF THE POLICY
COMMITTEES- THAT I'VE BEEN
SITTING ON AS CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS MANY OF THE
BILL'S NOT JUST THIS ONE THE
BILLS THAT WERE TAKING ACTION
ON TODAY ARE COMING TO.
APPROPRIATIONS AND I YOU KNOW
I'M GOING TO BE VOTING ON A
FOLLOWING THE CHAIR TODAY- BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE PREPARATIONS WILL
BE LOOKING AT THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF ALL OF THE BILLS
COMING BEFORE US AND SO MY VOTE
TODAY SHOULD NOT BE IN ANY ANY
INDICATION POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
OF THE DISPENSATION OF ANY OF
THE BILL SO JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT. IT'S ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU CENTER. BUT DEALS.
OKAY SO- THE MOVE THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
DON DONNA HI WILK NO WELL NO
ALLEN ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
ANGELA HI GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD AYE CHAN HI CHAN AYE
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS HI
SENATOR GLAZERS HI HILL. HI
HILL AYE HUESO HI HUESO I JONES
NO JONES NO NIELSEN. PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE WIENER. CHINA HAS
ENOUGH YOU MIGHT WANT TO PUT IT
ON CALL GET A BILL I HAS ENOUGH
TO GET OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK YOU.
OKAY NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO OF
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR CHAIRMAN
GREAT GOOD MORNING. SOON AS YOU
GET YOUR NEW. MIKE SANITIZER.
WE WILL CALL YOU FORWARD
WELCOME GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING SHERMAN SENATORS- THANK
YOU FOR THE SANITISE MICROPHONE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY
BILL HERE THIS MORNING. BEVERS
AT THIS COMMITTEES WELL WHERE
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE FINEST- HORSERACING
INDUSTRIES IN THE COUNTRY. AND
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
WE'VE HAD SOME EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING TIMES. THERE'S BEEN
A RUN OF THE COUNTRY COUNTIES
THAT OCCURRED EARLY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. MORE RECENTLY WE'VE
HAD THE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
CAUSED BY THE CURRENT PANDEMIC.
THE RESPONSE OF THIS CRISIS THE
CALIFORNIA RACING INDUSTRY AND
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD OF ADOPTED NEW STRINGENT
RULES REGULATIONS PROTOCOLS
RANGING FROM MEDICATION REFORM
ADVANCE VETERINARIAN SCREENING.
USE OF RIDING CROP TRACK
MAINTENANCE AMONGST MANY OTHER
THINGS INCLUDING THE USE OF NEW
HIGH TECH DIAGNOSTIC EQUIPMENT.
THESE WIDE RANGING REFORMS AND
PROTOCOLS HAVE LED TO A SAFER
RACING. INDUSTRY AND A SPIKE.
AFTER REFUSE ME THE SPIKE IN
FATAL BREAKDOWNS. IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THE RECENTLY RELEASED C.
H. R. B. INVESTIGATIVE REPORT
FOUND NO ILLEGAL MEDICATIONS OF
ANY OF THE CORTES THE CURRENT
SEVENTY THERE BETWEEN DECEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN ADDITION A
DETAILED REPORT BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE HAS FOUND NO
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING DURING THAT
SAME PERIOD. BOTH CHAIRMAN DODD
MYSELF OF UNDERTAKEN SERIOUS
EFFORTS OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO ADDRESS AND ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
HAVE THE HIGHEST STANDARD. OF
RACING PROTOCOLS. WE WANTED
BILLS BOTH IN THE FAMILY IN THE
SENATE THIS YEAR TO BUILD ON
LAST YEAR'S EFFORTS- WE WILL
CONTINUE. TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD. TO THAT END I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. HERE TODAY. I DON'T KNOW.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GRAHAM YOU
HAVE LOUIS BROWN AND TIM ON
ROBBINS BOTH ON THE PHONE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE THE- MR
BROWN. MR ROBBINS. START WITH
MR BRADY. MORNING THEN CHAIRMAN.
GOOD MORNING. PLEASE PROCEED.
YOUR MINISTER LOUIS BROWN ON
BEHALF A CALIFORNIA STORY OF
RAISING FARES CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY CHAIRMAN GRAY WANTS TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO HIM
AND YOU AS WELL AS YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR- THE
EFFORTS MADE OVER THIS LAST
YEAR TO IMPROVE ANIMAL WELFARE
ACT CALIFORNIA THREE TRACKS.
THREE VERY PROUD OF OUR RECORD.
DANNEL WALTER HOW WE PLACE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
ANIMALS OUR FORCES AS WELL AS
OUR- JOCKEYS AND TRAINERS- AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS NOW WE THINK THAT THE-
REQUIREMENTS BUT IN EIGHTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I WILL
ONLY ENHANCE THE SAFETY
MEASURES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE- BY PROVIDING. GREATER
FOR VETERINARIANS TO INSPECT
AND REVIEW THE HORSES PRIOR TO
COMING TO A RACE TRACK AND IT'S
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR BROWN MR ROBBINS ARE YOU I'M
FINE. YES I AM POLICE BOMB
ROBIN SPEAKING JUST BY WAY OF A
QUICK INTRODUCTION I HAVE. BUT
IN THE END OF RAISING
DEPARTMENT JUST CALIFORNIA
TRACKS DURING TO BRING ABOUT
THE LAST FORTY YEARS WHICH
INCLUDED A ONE TIME OR ANOTHER
SENATE NEED A HOLLYWOOD PARK IN
DELAMAR. CURRENTLY ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF RACING THAT- BILL
MAHER THOROUGHBRED CLUB. LET ME
FIRST SAY WE ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE SHERMAN GRAY'S
LEADERSHIP ON LEGISLATION THIS
ASSIGNED TO ENHANCE THE SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE READY.
RAISING SHE AND EQUINE
ATHLETES. THERE WAS- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
LEGISLATURE UPON ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE INDUSTRY
LEADER. IN EQUINE SAFETY
RESEARCH WELFARE AND AFTER
CARE- IN THE LAST YEAR ND A
HALF AS WAS NOTED THAT THE
CALIFORNIA REGION INDUSTRY IS
IMPLEMENTING ENHANCED PROTOCOLS.
PROCEDURES TO MEDICATION
RESTRICTIONS. OVERSIGHT AND THE
OVERALL SAFETY OF OUR WORKERS
FIGHTERS AND WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING BOARD SPECIFICALLY
DOCTOR. ARE YOU THERE WHO IS
OUR CALIFORNIA HE CLIMBED
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. INSTEAD
CHANGES ALL WITH A FOCUS AND
EMPHASIS FUND REDUCING INJURIES
AND IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT MANY THE SAME
MEASURES AND PROTOCOLS WE
ESTABLISHED. DUE TO THE SUCCESS
THAT WE HAVE RECENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA BEING IMPLEMENTED
IMPLEMENTED. MANY RACETRACKS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. HAVING
SEVEN THAT WE ARE IS NOT DONE
BUT ICAN SAY THE RESULTS HAVE
BEEN VERY ENCOURAGING FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS AT THE OMAR-
HELLO WE HAVE BEEN IN NORTH
AMERICA SAY THIS MAJOR
RACETRACK- THE BROUGH THESE
STRINGENT REFORMS WORK.
ABSOLUTE SHOWING THE RESULTS
NOT JUST IN DEL MAR BUT
SIGNIFICANT INJURY REDUCTIONS
OF THE NOTED AT SANTA ANITA AS
WELL IN THIS IN THIS LAST YEAR.
I'M TRYING FIND SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS IS COMBINED WITH THE
ENHANCED REGULATIONS THAT ARE
IN AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
WOULD HELP TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING.
CONTINUES TO BE THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR SAFETY AND WELFARE
IN OUR INDUSTRY THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU KNOWLEDGE
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEMTHERE IS ONE. PLEASE PROCEED HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE SURE CAN HI
LEVINE MY NAME IS SANDRA HAD
STRONG AND MY DAUGHTER ASKED ME
TO COME SINCE SHE HAS TO BE AT
SCHOOL AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
SHE'S A HORSE LOVER THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING. OKAY LET'S MOVE TO- IN
THE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THERE'S SOMEBODY IN ONE
TWELVE ARE YOU. MORE THAN
LIKELY AGAINST OR STAFF I CAN'T
SEE WITH. ALL MY GOODNESS THAT
SENATOR WILK ISN'T ISN'T AB
RIGHT. BOB SO THERE'S NOBODY
THERE SO THANK YOU I WILL NO
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE.
MODERATOR FAMILY FOUNDATION
BIDDLE'S. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN INTELLECTUAL SUPPORT
FOR AB ONE NINE SEVEN FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
ANY ON THE- NO SIR I HAVE NO
INSURANCE SUPPORT FOR AB ONE
ONE NINE SEVEN FOUR LET'S MAKE
THAT REQUEST ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB ONE NINE
SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I HAVE NO INSURANCE SUPPORT FOR
THE AUTHOR. OKAY LET'S. MOVE ON
TO THE OPPOSITION AND FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS. NOW LET'S
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. IN OPPOSITION TO
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR SEEING
NONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AND THERE IS NOBODY
THERE Q. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. YES SIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR AB ONE NINE SEVEN FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE NINE
SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY PRESS WANTED
THE ROLE AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ON THE LINE SHOWING
OPPOSITION FOR THAT AUTHOR
WE'LL TRY THAT ONE MORE TIME A
MODERATOR PLEASE. YES SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE NINE
SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY NOW PRESS
ONE ZERO. NO ONE SHERMAN
OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE NINE
SEVEN FOUR THERE. THANKS
MODERATE GOOD WORK THERE- OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THIS BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BILL
SAYS CENTER JONES MOVES THE
BILL ANY DISCUSSION SENATOR
RUBIO. YES VERY QUICKLY THANK
YOU TERM I WANTED TO START
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
MEASURE- I HAVE SENT ANY TO
RACETRACK IN MY DISTRICT AND WE
HAVE YOU KNOW IN YEARS PAST I
HEARD SOME OF THE TRAGEDIES IN
AND MOST OF THAT THE RACETRACKS
ACROSS THE STATE AND SELL
SAFETY. OF THE HORSES AND
JOCKEYS IS A VERY IMPORTANT TO
ALL OF US AND SO I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ONE
OF CORPORATE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THAT STUFF
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND- WITH
THAT I. ALSO WITH THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION- ANY-
OTHER COMMENTS SEEING NINE. MR
SECRETARY CAN WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM FOR
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REMINDER
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU HAVE YOUR
MAXON- MY GREAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I APOLOGIZE. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY QUICKLY OKAY
PERFECT SO AGAIN THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR EIGHTY NINETEEN
APPROPRIATIONS DODD. AYE DODD
AYE WILK HI WELCOME AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI. ANGELA
ORANGES HI. FORGES HI BRADFORD
HI BROWN'S HI CHIU HI JOHN HI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. WITH A
LASER SLEEP IN GLAZER. THEY
SLEEP IN OR IS ON ANOTHER CALL.
YEAH YES GOOD GLAZER. I KNEW.
SENATOR GLAZERS HI SENATOR
GLAZERS ARE HELLO DON'T DO
REMOTE VOTING HILL HI HILL AYE
HUESO BY WAY I'D JONES HI.
JONES HI NIELSEN AYE NELSON AYE
PORTANTINO HI COURT HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE WIENER. CHAIRMAN HAS
FIFTEEN VOTES WHEN I PUT IT ON
CALL THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN
VOTES- THIS GERMAN- THE WE'RE
GONNA LEAVE IT ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT YOUR.
EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND TO YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS GOOD
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL. I'VE
REACHED AGREEMENT WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS AND I'M COMMITTED
TO ADDRESS THEIR OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS. AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT IS A CRITICAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURE THE CLOSES LOOSE
LOOPHOLES IN THE BIGGER THE
KEEN OPEN MEETING ACT. THIS
BILL ENFORCES EXISTING LAWS BY
REQUIRING THAT RELEVANT
BACKGROUND DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
PART OF OUR PUBLIC RECORD. BE
POSTED ONLINE WITHIN ONE
BUSINESS DAY OF THE MONTH OF
THE MATERIALS BEING PROVIDED TO
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BODY OR
FORTY EIGHT HOURS PRIOR TO A
PUBLIC MEETING OF A STATE
AGENCY BOARD OR COMMISSION
WHICHEVER IS EARLIER. AB TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT ALSO ENSURES THAT
THE PUBLIC IS OFFERED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON ANY
LISTED THE GENDER ITEM
PARTICULAR ITEMS DISCUSSED BY
SUBCOMMITTEES THAT OFTEN DO NOT
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. CHALLENGING A
LIFE THREATENING EMERGENCY SUCH
AS THE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS AND THE FAST APPROACHING
WILDFIRE SEASON. ARE RAPIDLY
SHIFTING OUR PUBLIC MEETINGS OF
STATE BODIES ONLINE AND TO TALK
TELECONFERENCE. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE MUST UPHOLD AND
STRENGTHEN CRITICAL
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS THE
PROVIDE AMPLE TIME AND
INFORMATION FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. I CONTINUE MY
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF OUR STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
OR OBSTACLES THEY MAY FACE IN
MAKING THESE PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE IN AN APPROPRIATE AND
TIMELY MANNER. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN PROTECTING THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT
TO SUE PARTICIPATION.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE ONGOING
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THE REQUIRES US
TO STAY AT HOME TO SAVE LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS TAYLOR JACKSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. JACKSON
PLEASE PERCY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK
ON THE BALLOT WELLS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND HER
TEAM IN OUR ADVOCACY WORK WITH
A VARIETY OF STATE BOARDS CNA
DISCOVERED THIS LOOPHOLE AND
BAGLEY KEENE WHICH PROMPTED THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU. WITH
THE MOVE TO REMOTE MEETINGS THE
MEDICAL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THE BILL IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
SO THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN
UNDERSTAND THE BUSINESS BEING
DONE AT THEIR STATE MEETING THE
DOCUMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
YOUR CREW DESCRIBED ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC ATHISMEETINGS UNDER
EXISTING BAGLEY KEENE OPEN
MEETING LAWS AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT WILL SIMPLY REQUIRE
PUBLIC SKATEBOARD PROVIDE THESE
MATERIAL BEFORE THE MEETING SO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
CAN FULLY UNDERSTAND. THE ITEM
BOARD WILL BE DISCUSSING AND
VOTING ON MANY STATE FOR
ALREADY WITH IS LAID OUT IN
EIGHTY TWENTY BECAUSE OF SOME
MAKES ONE CENTER ON A J. IS
ENOUGH INFORM AND PREPARE THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE CLIENT OF THE
DISCUSSION THE SPIRIT OF BAGLEY
CAN IS TO MAKE STATE OF ME
TRANSPARENT AND THE BILL LIVE
APPLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE URGE OUR AYE VOTE TODAY
ON. AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS JACKSON NOW THE
BEGIN WITH WHAT THIS IS HERE IN
THE GALLERY. C. A. DONE WE'RE
TO MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE WITH
THE CLOSE. IN THEIR OUR THIRTY.
THE MOVE NOW TO WITNESS WE TO
TESTIFY VIA TELE OR IF IT'S-
MODERATOR FOR PLEASE KNOW.
THANK I'M SORRY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ELECTION SUPPORT A BI
TWO EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
LOCAL TO THE LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
CURRENTLY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS MISS SAGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND NO ONE ELSE SHOWING SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW WHAT
WE'LL DO IS WE'LL MOVE TO-
LET'S LET'S JUST CHECK THE LINE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. YES SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AS A REMINDER. IT'S ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
JUDICIAL SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
THAT MODERATOR- NOW HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
FALL THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
ANY OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF OF
THE- CALIFORNIA RICE
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRIES SISSY SHOES ON THE
PHONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER. OKAY WELL MISTER BROWN
IF YOU'RE LISTENING WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OTHER WITNESSES AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU BACK
ON- PLEASE CALL AND- SO LET'S
MOVED ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE. LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWELVE ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE. MISTER BROWN. ARE
YOU AVAILABLE TO COMMENT. YES
MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW. JUST IN TIME YES SIR
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU SIR
I'LL BE QUICK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION AND OTHERS I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION- TO
THE AUTHOR HER STAFF AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
US- WE HAVE REACHED A
RESOLUTION ON. SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
WE HAVE AND WILL BE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION. CERTAINLY SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
GOOD DAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR BROWN- MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. PLEASE YES
PLEASE AND GENTLEMEN ANGELA FOR
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OPENMY NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THIS IS
MICHAEL MILLER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS BUT YOU WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
MEET THE DOCTOR THE SHOP
THEY'LL- WORK WITH THE CLOSELY
AND- PRECIADO WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS OUR ISSUES THANK MANY
STAFF AND HER STAFF AS WELL.
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU.
OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CALIFORNIA GIRLS LIKE IF THEY
DID SOMETHING AND THEN. NOT
THANK. ASSEMBLY GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHAT THE INITIAL
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DON'T KNOW WHEN
ALSO IN OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT THERE THANK
YOU MODERATOR HAVE AND- ASTON
OVERTIMES WILL NOW MOVE TO-
BACK TO BRING THE DISCUSSION TO
OUR MEMBERS CENTER NIELSEN.
REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY HAVE I AM
AWARE OF SOME OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS
CONCERNS HERE. AND AS OF MID
AFTERNOON YES. TO MY KNOWLEDGE
ARE NOT RESOLVED- MY STAFF
CALLED YOUR OFFICE AND DID NOT
GET A RESPONSE SEVEN. IN YOUR
MICROPHONE PLEASE HAVE A
SEVERAL BATTERY YET BUT I'D
LIKE TO KNOW THE SPECIFIC. I'D
LIKE TO KNOW THE SPECIFIC LET'S
START ALL OVER AGAIN. I ACT
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME CONCERN
IN THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE ABOUT
OF INFORMATION THEY WOULD HAVE
TO PROVIDE SOME OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS DO NOT HAVE DEEP
POCKETS MANY EMPLOYEES. AND THE
THEY WERE SEEKING AMENDMENTS WE
CALLED YOUR OFFICE YESTERDAY
AND DID NOT GET A RESPONSE CAN
AND THEY DIDN'T THE TESTIMONY
HERE TO NOT EXPRESS WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY DO THAT
ACCOMMODATES THEIR CONCERNS
COULD YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE THAT WILL HELP
THEM OUT TO GET HIM TO. NOT
OPPOSE VISIT YEAH I THINK WE
RIVER DRESSED QUITE A FEW OF
THOSE PARTICULARLY- HAD-
CONVERSATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
RICE COMMISSION AND THEY
BROUGHT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
QUITE FRANKLY I DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT AND SO WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT IS QUITE FRANKLY IS THE
COST. OF BECAUSE SOME OF THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT COSTLY TO THEM
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVE SO THEY CAN MAKE
SURE THE INFORMATION IS POSTED
TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS SO THEY
TOO CAN. AFFORD PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC OUTRAGE- OF EACH ONE
OF THEIR ORGANIZATION SO- WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE- I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM-
AND I AS YOU CAN TELL US SOME
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALL THAT WE
HAVE COMMITTEE BUT THOSE WITH
WITH THEIR IN. CAN SO IT'S ME
IS CAN ABOUT THE TO THE
INNOVATION WHEN YOU HAVE
QUALITY. PROVIDE MISSION TIMELY
MANNER ON THE- AN AS WELL
STORING THAT IF. S. THE AS OF
TODAY THOSE OF MEN ARE. IN THE
BAY THAT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT
CAN YOU KNOW WE'RE WITH THEM
WE'RE WHERE WHERE YOU INTEND
AND THE KNOW WHAT COULD WHAT
COMMITTEE AND THAT I WOULD YOU
KNOW I'VE DONE KNOW IS THAT
WHERE POWER INTO PRO. BILL I'M
NOT SURE OF THE CAN THE WILL
COULD WITH THE OKAY EITHER I
ABSTAIN FOR THIS POINT THERE'S
SOME AMENDMENTS ARE LOOK AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YET YES
THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN DIED I'VE
HEARD THIS SAME- CONCERNS BY
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY I DO
HAVE FAITH IN YOU IS AN AUTHOR
THOUGH SO I AM GOING TO MOVE
YOUR BILL TODAY THANK YOU BUT
IF THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
ADDRESSED APPROACH THAT ON CAN
HAVE TO BE YOU KNOW ON THE
FLOOR AND RIGHTFULLY SO. THANK
YOU RIGHT THANK YOU. MOTION BY
SENATOR WILK ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. MR SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THE- IS THAT. I'M SORRY-
CENTER BORDERS I DIDN'T LOOK
FOUGHT NOT FAR FROM MY THE
RELOCATE OUR TODAY FURTHER TO
THE LEFT I SENT I HEAR. I THINK
A CENTER AND CENTER NIELSEN-
DESCRIBED EVERYTHING IN DETAIL.
IF SHE'S ABLE TO GET THE AUTHOR
IS ABLE TO GET. ON TO A
COMPROMISE THAT SATISFIES THE
INTERESTS. OF THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY- THEN I THINK- THIS
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL FOR VOTE
I'LL BE UPSTANDING UNTIL WE SEE
THAT THAT- RESOLUTION HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I SIMPLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
MISTER SECTOR COOLEY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SHE AND ONTARIO
YES THIS IS FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS DODD.
DOT HI WILK ALL RIGHT WILK AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
NIGEL I DON'T MIND BARGES WILL
ONLY MOVE IT BORDERS. BRADFORD
HI BRADFORD AYE CHAN AYE CHIANG
GHAZI. AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER AYE SENATOR
GLAZERS ONLINE HILL HI HILL AYE
HUESO BY. HUESO HI JONES.
NIELSEN. IT TOOK THAT AS
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE WIENER. IN
ANOTHER SEVEN ONE WHEN I WANT
ONE OF MY WHEN I PUT IT ON CALL
OKAY THAT BILL IS ON CALL OUR
NEXT BILL IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWO OH FIVE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALM LIKE YOUR
DIVE- CENTER WIENER WAS GOING
TO- PRESENT THIS BILL HE IS NOT
HERE CENTER HUESO IS AGREED TO
DO SO YOU CAN PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF THE AUTHOR SENATOR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS-
REALLY GOOD BILL GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY HERE RELATED TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THIS BILL
CREATES THE A COMMUNITY
RESPONSE INITIATIVE. THAT
STRENGTHENS EMERGENCIES-
SYSTEMS. THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS ACT. CRISIS ACT. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF IMPLEMENTING
AND EVALUATING THE CRISIS GRANT
PILOT PROGRAM. TO STIMULATE AND
SUPPORT COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT.
IN EMERGENCY RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES THAT DO NOT REQUIRE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. AS
SPECIFIED IS IF YOU REVIEW THE
FILE MISTER CHAIRMAN IT ENJOYS.
EXTREMELY BROAD BROAD COMMUNITY
SUPPORT THERE'S BEEN A REALLY
GOOD COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION
EFFORT OF PUTTING THIS BILL
TOGETHER. AND THERE IS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. WELL DONE LAST MINUTE
PRESENTATION CENTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT I WILL BE
MOVING ON TO- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- ELIZABETH- THE ROUTE.
THAT IF I'VE GOT THAT
PRONUNCIATION RIGHT ON THE
PHONE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. COULD YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. YEAH HI GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BETTER
AT LEAST RESTORED- ORGANIZER
WITH THE COALITION AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION- IF
THEY WERE NUMBERED BY FAMILIES
WHO HAVE THE WINDSHIELD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE ARE A PART
BECAUSE SOMETHING OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR AND- URGE THE
COMMITTEE FRIEND I'VE ALL-
INTERCONVERT DOESN'T SOLVE MY
COULD ENGINEER WAS EXPERIENCING
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND WANT
TO RUN AWAY FROM HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY THE MISTAKE OF
CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
MADE INSTEAD OF A MENTAL HEALTH
INTERVENTION IT WOULD ONLY
ESCALATE THE SITUATION- DURING
THE. THE THREE NINE NOT LOOKING
WITHOUT THAT JUNIOR WAS A
THREAT AND THAT SHE COULD CALM
HIM DOWN AT THE HER THE
OPPORTUNITY THEY WERE. YOUR END
OF GETTING TO. I'M SORRY KILLED
BY THE- OFFICERS HE WAS ONLY
FOR. HE WAS SHOT TWICE IN THE
LOWER BODY AND THEN OFFICER
SHOT IT IS NOT THREE TIMES IN
THE BACK AS HE WAS CRAWLING
AWAY FROM THEM- THANK MY
COUSIN'S MURDER EVENT HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN SUPPORTING LIKE
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES TO
THE POLICE. I'M ALSO PART OF AN
ECONOMIST- COLLECTIVE- HERE IN
L. A. COUNTY CALLED THE
COMMUNITY OKAY NINE ONE ONE. AS
OF NOW WE'RE NOT A RECORD
RESPONSIBLE TO PROVIDE VERY
SKILL BUILDING WORKSHOPS AND
TRAINING SO THAT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CAN BUILD SKILLS ANY
DIFFERENT AREAS. THE PROVIDE
TRAINING- IN CONFLICT
RESOLUTION ON THAT BUILDING
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY FUNCTION
KALRA PROTECT OURSELVES-
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AND MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND LASTLY FIRST AID
FLASH ONE HERE WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THESE TRACTORS AREAS
IN WHICH WE CAN INTERVENE AND
PROVIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES TO REDUCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
RESPONDING. AND I DO WANT TO
QUICKLY HOW DOES THAT THESE ARE
NOT NEW EVERYTHING MANY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
INDIGENOUS AND BLACK COMMUNITY
HAVE ORGANICALLY DEVELOPED AND
USED SIMILAR. CARE FOR YEARS-
THE OTHER WAS THAT THE MOST
MARGINALIZED KNOW THAT CALLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT THE
ANSWER. I WANT NOT TO PROCEED.
THE INCREDIBLE MUTUAL IT THAT
YOU KNOW I ROCKET DURING THE
TIME. ARE OF THAT MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY. ARE SURVIVED AND
HAVE ACCESS TO RESEARCH.
BECAUSE OF THE WHO ENJOY
EFFORTS WHICH ARE MORE THAN OCT
NOT BY AND WE CAN TO THAT ON
OUR- ON THE SYSTEM. TO KEEP US
SAFE ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY HAVE
TO. LEFT OUT AND KEEP TO BATTLE
WE ARE ONLY ALREADY HAVE BEEN
THIS WAY WITHOUT. BUT WE ALSO
ALREADY HAVE A- WILL WITH OUR
OWN COMMUNITY AND OUR
COMMUNITIES KNOW WHAT IT TAKES
TO. ENOUGH TO OUR OWN COMMUNITY.
SO WE'RE URGING THE COMMITTEE
WELL YEAH ON EIGHTY. TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE IT WILL
SOLUTIONS THE SAME LIVES FINE
BUT- IN COMING BASED
ALTERNATIVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERIES. THREE
NINE ANY WITNESSES IN ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THIRTEEN DONE- NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. YES WE AND IS ALSO FOR A
TWENTY FIFTY FOR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE- ACTED. VIRTUAL MY
NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN COURT.
MY THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BARBARA WEAVER ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JUSTIN RATHER ON
BEHALF OF REDUCE THE CHANGE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BENJAMIN TRAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA KIND I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. LINE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EVERY OTHER
AMERICA WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANDERSON WITH THE ARC IN
UGT CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT. ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS WHO SHALL GO ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER INTO COURT. NINE SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHRISTIAN CHURCH MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY SHOCKING APATHY A BOX
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI. IN
NINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS LUCY
SALCEDO CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF NOT
IN SUPPORT. MY FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SIR
NUMBER DEMAND A MEETING OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BARRELS ON BEHALF
OF HIM BEEN HEARD IN THE COURT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARTIN OR
DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REBECA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL AT THE VISION
OF POST WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THINK
RANCHO BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT. MY NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND SPORT THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING READING OFF OF ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE CO
FOUNDERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
HINMAN DEAN ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLR AT POLICY LINK
ALSO IF YOU FEEL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA ENTIRE POLICE TERROR
PROJECT BERKELEY FREE CLINIC.
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER JUSTICE
TEAMS THAT WORK OPENPOWER
PROJECTS HOW YOU DOING PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES STOP TERROR
OPPRESSION BY POLICE COALITION
UT W. ACTUALLY LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY AND DO YOU ACCEPT
THIS COALITION. IS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
SIXTY LINE OF THE- THERE WILL
TO OF COLOR STRONG SUPPORT AND
CLOSE. THE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF A REMINDER SHOWS
UP FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN A REMINDER
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. NO
ONE ELSE WAS SUPPORTER PLEASE
CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK
MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE LIGHTS
NOW- FOR IN THE- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- WISHING TO VOICE
OPPOSITION- TO AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE.
ANNOUNCED. YES SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. IT IS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION.
SKEWS ME MODERATOR I KIND OF
THE JUMP THE GUN THERE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS
ANYBODY YOU KNOW HERE- IN IN
THIS BUILDING AND- TO VOICE
OPPOSITION LOOKING UP AND
SEEING NINE. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ROOM TWELVE. ONE TWELVE AND
THERE'S NOBODY THERE MONTEREY
PLEASE CONTINUE I APOLOGIZE.
YES SIR AND LATER ON AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I WANTED TO SHOW UP EDUCATIONAL
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO INITIAL IN
OPPOSITION AT THE CENTRE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR GOOD
WORK WE WANT TO BRING IT BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS AND HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
NIELSEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE GEO
COMMITTEE. THIS IS ANOTHER BILL
IN A LONG LINE OF BILLS THAT
HAVE BECOME A HABIT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE NOW THIS IS A
POLICY COMMITTEE NOT A FISCAL
COMMITTEE. BUT I RAISED THE
CONCERN. THAT WE'RE NOW GETTING
IN THE HABIT OF OBLIGING FUTURE
BUDGETS TO FUND SOMETHING. AND
WE WILL VOTE FOR IT NOW. PUT IT
ON THE BOOKS AND THAT CREATES A
PERCEPTION OR AN OBLIGATION
THAT IT WILL BE FUNDED IN THE
FUTURE. I THINK THAT'S VERY
POOR POLICY AND THEREFORE I
CANNOT SUPPORT SUCH FIELDS.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
SUPPORTING TINA WOULD YOU LIKE
TO LIVE OUT YOUR DISCLAIMER.
YEAH I MADE MY DISCLAIMER EARLY
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA LOOKING
AT ALL THE FISCAL ISSUES AS
THINGS GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND DON'T TAKE BY
VOTE TODAY IS AN INDICATION OF
HOW. THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE ACTION
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. MR
FORTINO. NONE CAN WE ANNOUNCE
THE DOGS WERE BACK HERE AT AND
OTHER MEMBERS I DO I HAVE A
MOTION. SKEWS ME CENTER WIENER
I'M SORRY DIDN'T LOOK OVER
THERE. PLEASE PROCEED. I THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I'M
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
LEGISLATION- WE NEED TO SET UP
SYSTEMS AND SUPPORT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I SAID THAT WE
DON'T DEFAULT TO POLICE
INTERVENTION FOR SITUATIONS
WHETHER ON MENTAL HEALTH OR
HOMELESSNESS OR ANY OTHER
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS THAT DON'T
REQUIRE A POLICE OFFICER WITH A
GUN- TO INTERVENE WE NEED TO
TAKE A MUCH MORE. MULTIFACETED
MULTI DISCIPLINARY APPROACH AND
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE AS A
SOCIETY FRANKLY BECOME- I'M
GONNA BE HONEST A LITTLE BIT
LAZY IN THE FAULTING IS JUST
HAVING THE POLICE DEAL WITH
EVERYTHING I AM WHEN IT COMES
TO ADDICTION AND MENTAL HEALTH
AND HOMELESSNESS AND SO MANY
OTHER CHALLENGES WE HAVE AS A
SOCIETY- IN SO MANY SITUATIONS
WE DO NOT NEED A POLICE
OFFICER. WITH A GUN TO RESPOND
TO THAT SITUATION WE NEED A
PROFESSIONAL WHO CAN PROVIDE D.
AND HELP SOMEONE- AND DE
ESCALATING GET PEOPLE IN THE
SERVICES THAT'S THE DIRECTION
WE NEED TO GO- AS A SOCIETY SO
THAT OUR POLICE OFFICERS CAN
ACTUALLY FOCUS. ON M. CRIME
SCITUATE WHERE YOU NEED A
POLICE OFFICER- TO BE INVOLVED
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT IT IS SETTING A
FOUNDATION- WE WILL YOU KNOW
AND OF COURSE WE WILL WORK. IN
THE BUDGET GOING FORWARD TO
HELP BUT THIS IS ABOUT.
SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR EFFORTS-
TO TAKE A MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL.
AND MULTI DISCIPLINARY
APPROACH- TO SOME OF THE
SOCIETAL CHALLENGES THAT SIMPLY
DO NOT REQUIRE AN ARMED POLICE
OFFICER SAWYER IS AN AYE VOTE.
THANK CENTER WINNER CAN I TAKE
THAT AS A MOTION SIR. SO MOVE
ADDS CENTER RUBIO AS- SORRY
WELL I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THE POINT AND SO I'LL JUST DUMP
TACKLE TO CALL MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
THAT THIS ISN'T AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO TRY AND MITIGATE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WERE
HAVING ACROSS OUR STATE IN
TERMS OF- YOU KNOW- THE
COMMUNITY AND SOME OF THE
CONCERNSARE HAVING AS IT
PERTAINS TO POLICE BRUTALITY
AND I THINK THIS PILOT PROGRAM
IS JUST A WAY TO SEE. IF IT
WORKS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SEE IF IT WORKS WE CAN
IMPLEMENTED ACROSS. THE STATE
BUDGET GIVEN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IS
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD SUPPORT IT AND I
ABSOLUTELY. I'M IN FAVOR OF
THIS THANK YOU. WHAT ELSE
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR
LAST NIGHT I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH HER FOR A LITTLE
BIT SEVERAL CONSERVE. THERE ARE
TWO OR THREE CONCERNS I HAVE
ABOUT THE BILL- BUT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND-
WATCHING AND AS IT GOES FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WITH
THAT- WE HAVE A MOTION BY-
CENTER WIENER. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE APPROPRIATION SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIFTY
EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS DODD HI. DOT HI
WILK HI WILK HI ALLEN. HI ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HI
THERE JUST AREN'T BORDERS HI
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI
CHIANG HI JOHN HI GALGIANI HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. SENATOR
GLAZERS HI SENATOR GLAZERS HI
HILLS MYLAN HIGH. HELLO ALL
RIGHT SO HI WE'RE SO JOHN I
JONES HI NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO HI
RUBIO HI RUBIO HI WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE FIFTEEN TO ONE
SHERMAN THE BILL IS OUT. THANK
YOU. WE'LL NOW- I WILL BE
PRESENTING THE NEXT TWO BILLS
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN- AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN CENTER WILL GUIDE. CAN
YOU PLEASE PROCEED WHERE ARE
YOU. WITH THE CHAIR. TIMING IS
EVERYTHING. A DEAD. BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL YEAH. VERY VERY BAD
SO WE ARE. RIGHT. THERE WHAT
WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE OVER THE
PROCEEDINGS AS I PRESENT TO AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE POLICE.
UP NEXT IS AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE FROM BIGELOW I DO NOT HAVE
A SCRIPT HERE SAYING WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION IS I KNOW IS TO
PASS TO DO WE KNOW WHAT IT TO
THE FLOOR TO. THE PROBE TO
PROBE SO DO PASS. TWO PROBES
CHEDDAR AT SHERMAN DODD PLEASE
PROCEED. MISTER NUMBERS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE WHICH
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESTAURANT ALCOHOL LICENSES TO
THE COUNTY OF NAPA. ED MARIPOSA
BOOK MARIPOSA NAP ARE WILLING
COUNTIES WHOSE BUDGETS ARE
MOSTLY FUNDED BY TOURISM
DOLLARS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
CURRENT FORMULA IS TIED TO THE
POPULATION THESE COUNTIES THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES DOES NOT
REFLECT THE BIG NUMBER OF
VISITORS EACH YEAR IN
UNNECESSARILY HARD ECONOMIES
FOR BOTH THESE A COUNTIES
COUNTIES. AB TWO FOUR FIFTY
NINE WILL HELP MARIPOSA NAPA
TRACK EVEN MORE VISITORS FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD AS OUR
ECONOMY RECOVERS FROM CLOVER
NINETEEN. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. TESTIFYING OVER THE
PHONE IS VERY POUT POSE A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. KEVIN KIANA
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
THIS IS KEVIN CHAMOMILE AND NOW.
YES SIR YES SUPERVISOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEVIN
CANNON. CHAIR OF AMERICA'S THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
CURRENT NUMBER ON SALE LIQUOR
LICENSES IN MARIPOSA COUNTY IS
ROUGHLY BASED ON THE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PERMANENT
RESIDENCE WE HOST FOUR TO FIVE
MILLION VISITORS A YEAR TO
YOSEMITE VALLEY A VERY VALUABLE
PART OF OUR COUNTY THAT'S AN
INCREASE OF TWO AND A HALF
MILLION VISITORS. PER YEAR
SINCE 198080% OF THESE VISITORS.
OVERNIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE PARK
MOST IN THE GATEWAY COMMUNITIES.
COLUSA COUNTY RE. THREE TIMES
READ FOR HOST TAXES AS IT DOES
PROP TAX. AGAIN THAT GIVES SOME
INDICATION OF WHAT IT TOOK
DEPENDENT COUNTY WE ARE. MOST
QUALITY LODGING FACILITIES
REQUIRE FULL SERVICE RESTAURANT
WITH ON SITE LIQUOR SERVICE
COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
SUPERVISORS ARE FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS LIQUOR
LICENSE FEE INCREASE WHICH IS
TARGETED FOR FOOD SERVICE
FACILITIES WITH A MINIMUM
SEATING CAPACITY OF FIFTY. MANY
BUSINESSES LITERALLY SERVE
MILLIONS OF TOURISTS ANNUALLY
WITH OVERNIGHT ACCOMMODATIONS
AND FOOD SERVICE WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR NEIGHBOR
COUNTIES ON THESE ISSUES AS
FULLY ONE AND A HALF MILLION OF
THOSE VISITORS COME ON ROUTE
ONE FORTY THROUGH THE TOWN OF
MERCED. AND INTO THE TOWN OF
MARIPOSA AND EVENTUALLY ON
DECEMBER NATIONAL PARK.
PURPOSING COUNTY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
MISTER SUPERVISOR NOW AT THIS
TIME WE WILL MOVE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY TO TESTIFY. SEEING
NONE WE WILL MOVE TO ROOM A ONE
ONE TWO. NO ONE THERE GET THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
OUR MODERATOR RICK VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE SO
MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROP ANY INDEED ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY NINE AND WILL BEGIN.
REGISTER PLEASE DON'T SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ALTHOUGH MY
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALL IT OR ON
BEHALF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS GRATEFUL CENTER DOT
AND SHOWING THEM DAY LOWER
DRIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY SIX MY
THIRTY SIX RELATED OPEN.
MELISSA WERNER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
LADIES. GO AHEAD MODERATOR.
THANK YOU VERY AT LEAST JOHN AS
A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
LAKE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING VALERIE
NARROWED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE OF THE ZERO OUT OF
TIME. I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
SHOWING SUPPORTER. MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND ASKING ONE FINAL
TIME. I REQUEST YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
WANTED APART THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO AT THIS POINT
WE'LL NOW TURN TO POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION. WE'LL BEGIN HERE IN
THE GALLERY. SAYING NINE IF WE
COULD HAVE THE CAMERA SHOOT ON
ROOM ONE ONE TWO. SIGNAL TURNED
BACK TERM MODERATOR MODERATOR
CAN YOU CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
CHAU OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT
FOR AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE.
ANOTHER REMINDER IF YOU I JUST
WANTED TO SHOW YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND I KNOW WE SHOULD
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO AT THIS POINT WILL PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
I HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
HILL. SEEING NO OTHER MIKES UP-
THE WILL ALLOW CHAIRMAN DIED TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT. MOTION IS- THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND SEND TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS DOT
BY DOT HI WILL HI WELCOME HI
ALLEN HI. ALLEN HI ANGELA.
ANGELA HI ORANGES ARE LARGEST
AYE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD
HI CHIANG RAI CHIANG HI
GALGIANI. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
LOOKS LIKE A FIX. SENATOR
GLAZERS HI SENATE HI HILL HI
HILL HI WHERE SOME. BY WEST SO
I'D JONES HI JONES HI NIELSEN.
HI NIELSEN HI PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO HI RUBIO.
RUBIO RIGHT WIENER ALL RIGHT
WIENER AYE EIGHT FIFTEEN ZERO
CHAIRMAN OF BILLS OUT. BILLS
OUT FIFTEEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS CHAIRMAN NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND CHAIRMAN DODD
WILL PRESENT THE BILL. THANK
YOU- BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR CURRENTLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AT SIX RECEIVE A
PORTION OF CALIFORNIA STATE
LOTTERY FUNDING. SOME OF WHICH
IS DEEMED RESTRICTED IT CAN BE
ONLY USED FOR THE PURCHASE OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
HOWEVER OVER 60% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS HAVE A
SURPLUS OF RESTRICTED LOTTERY
FUNDS LEAVING OVER EIGHTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN TOUCH. THIS
BILL WITHOUT CREATING A MANDATE
SO WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO USE
RESTRICTED LOTTERY FUNDS TO
PROVIDE HOUSING ASSISTANCE. IT
OR FOOD ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH HUNGER HOUSING
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE CLOVER NINETEEN. RIGHT
NOW CAMPUS CLOSURES AND CREATED
EXPENSES AT THE SAME TIME THAT
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
MAY HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IT IS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE STUDENT
GROUPS AND FACULTY
ORGANIZATIONS. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TESTIFYING OVER THE PHONE
IS DEBBIE KLEIN PRESIDENT OF
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR MS KLEIN.
I KNOW I AM OPEN. SHE'S NOT ON
THE LINE. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MS KLEIN IS
CURRENTLY NOT ON THE LINE AND
WE WILL COME BACK FOR HER- IF
SHE HOPS ON THE LINE SO AT THIS
POINT. WE ARE LOOKING FOR-
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S
TRANSITION TO ROOM ONE ONE TWO.
AGAIN SAYING NINE OUR MODERATOR
CAN YOU SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER PEOPLE ON THE LINE THEY
WILL WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ENFORCEABLE ALLY NUMBER FORTY
TWO WE REALIZE NOW OPEN GOOD
MORNING- THIS CHAIR MEMBERS
LOUIS MANDE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KATRINA RENDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN PROJECT KATIE AND MARK.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT
AVAILABLE BE HAPPY TO
CALIFORNIA AS COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IF YOU'RE LINE NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. BONTA
WARNER WE HAPPEN THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
DEPART THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GLIDE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT MEMBERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TRANSPORT
SPELL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI KATIE HARTMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT. AND
LADIES GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER
SOME POTENTIAL SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MY TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DOCTOR DEADLINE CAN YOU ALL
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. OH GREAT I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING
AVAILABLE PREVIOUSLY DIDN'T
GOOD MORNING CHAIR DODD AND
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AYE
DADDY KLEIN PROFESSOR OF
ANTHROPOLOGY AT GOVERNMENT
COLLEGE AND PRESIDENT OF THE
STATE WIDE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIKE K. TWELVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE
STATE LOTTERY FUNDING WHICH IS
SPLIT INTO TWO CATEGORIES
UNRESTRICTED FUNDS CAN BE SPENT
ON ANYTHING RELATED TO
EDUCATING OUR STUDENTS WELL
RESTRICTED FUNDS CAN ONLY BE
DONE INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
LAST YEAR 66% OF THE DISTRICTS
HAD A SURPLUS OF RESTRICTED
FUNDS. AND SOME DISTRICTS HAD A
SURPLUS HI SEVEN MILLION
INSTEAD OF LETTING THIS MONEY
OVER FROM YEAR TO YEAR
DISTRICTS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPTION OF USING IT TO FULFILL
THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC IN
RECESSION DISTRICTS COULD OU
RESPOND TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS I FACULTY WHO WORK
WITH STUDENTS EVERY DAY WE KNOW
BASIC NEEDS AN ACADEMIC SUCCESS
ARE INEXTRICABLY LINKED WHEN MY
STUDENTS ARE FOCUSED ON WHERE
TO GET THEIR NEXT MEAL AND
WHERE TO SLEEP. THEY ARE NOT
LIKELY TO SUCCEED IN MY CLASSES
OUR STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING NOW
MORE THAN EVER THIS BILL WOULD
GIVE DISTRICT ANOTHER TOOL FOR
HELPING OUR STUDENTS THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER. MATER CAN YOU
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL TO TESTIFY IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. I'D BE
GLAD TO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN MY
NUMBER TWENTY NINE ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. B.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING TURN MY NAME IS
INTERNET AND LONG AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AB AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE US THE
STUDENT CENTER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPRESENTING
TWO POINT ONE MILLION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. ALL PART OF
THIS BILL RECOGNIZE THAT PRIOR
TO THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
MANY STUDENTS STRUGGLE BASIC
NEEDS. I'M INDEPENDENT I'M
ENDEMIC IS ONLY EXACERBATED THE
BASIC NEEDS OF STUDENTS FROM
OVER 70% OF CURRENT STUDENTS OF
LOS SOME OR ALL THEIR SOURCES
OF INCOME AS A RESULT. AND
MAINTAINING. THANK YOU YEAH I
THINK YOU SPEAKER WHERE WE'RE
AT THEN ME TO STAGE AT THIS
POINT SO THANK. YOU MODERATOR
ANY OTHERS. SENATOR MIGHT
ADDITIONAL. OF TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
THE SAN DIEGO THE PALO VERDE
AND THE SAN BERNARDINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS-
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
INTELLECTUAL SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON
BOARD FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT FOUR
COULD CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK TO YOU
MOMENTARILY SO AT THIS POINT.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE THAT
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR WE
WILL OPEN IT WITH HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE IF WE
COULD TRANSITION DOWN TO ROOM
ONE ONE TWO. SEEING NINE WE'RE
GONNA RETURN ONCE AGAIN TO OUR
MODERATOR MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ENTERED ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO INSURANCE OPPOSITION TO IT
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO AT THIS
POINT WILL PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
OF MISTER CHAIRMAN SORRY I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
CONSTITUTIONALITY PROBLEMS- RE
PURPOSING SOME OF THE FUNDS-
FROM THE LOTTERY IN THIS
MANNER- ALSO- AS WE RECENTLY
LEARNED WITHOUT IT SAID THERE'S
A MYRIAD OF CHALLENGES AND
PROBLEMS WITH THE LOTTERY I
THINK THAT- REDIRECTING THEM
ARE EXPANDING THEIR- AREA
RESPONSIBILITIES IS. ALSO NOT
APPROPRIATE THIS POINT TIME AS
I'VE STATED BEFORE- WITH THE-
INEFFICIENCY OF THE LOTTERY AND
IT'S REALLY NOT LIVING UP TO
ITS PROMISES TO OUR STUDENTS.
IN SCHOOL. I THINK THE MORE
APPROPRIATE COURSE OF ACTION
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
TAKING AT THIS POINT TIME
REGARDING THE LOTTERY IS
FINDING A WAY TO UNWIND IT. AND
CLOSE IT DOWN SO I WILL
UNFORTUNATELY NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER JONES UP
NEXT SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIR WILK- I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T GROW THE PIE-
BASIC NEEDS FOR OUR STUDENTS-
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IS
GROWING EVERY DAY AND I IT'S
GONNA BE WORSE NEXT YEAR AND
SO. I LIKE A KNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANT- PROVISIONS THAT ARE
IN THIS BILL IT IS MY HOPE THAT
AS WE GO INTO THE BUDGET. FOR
NEXT YEAR- WITH THAT NEEDS
BEING GREATER THAN EVER THAT
WILL LOOK FOR WAYS TO GROW THAT
HIGH FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OVERALL. AND CERTAINLY FOR THE
BASIC NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
THAT ARE- IN IN GREAT NEED OF
OUR HELP SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS SAYING NINE. CAN I
HAVE A MOTION. MOVED BY CENTER
HILL IT THE MOTION ISDO DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND WITH
THAT LET'S CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS DODD. DODD.
I START ALL RIGHT WILK HI WILK
AYE ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE
EXCELLENT AYE HI ARCHULETA
FORGES. BRADFORD HI BRADFORD HI
CHIANG. GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS HI
SENATOR GLAZERS HI HILL HI HILL
HI WATSON HI HUESO AYE JONES NO.
JOHN SNOW NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO HI
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WIENER ALL
RIGHT WE HI. PLATOU CHAIRMAN
THAT BILLS ON. OKAY SO THAT
BILL IS OUT IS AGAIN DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITHOUT I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN THE GAVEL BACK
OVER TO OUR ILLUSTRIOUS CHAIRS
CENTER SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU
VICE YOU'RE WELCOME APPRECIATE
THAT- WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THE
ROLE FOR THE PREVIOUS- BOATS
CENTER HUESO DID YOU HAVE SAID
YOU WANT TO SAY. OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED FOR SECRETARY. OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE OPENING UP THE
ROLL CALL FIRST OFF IS B.
CONSENT ITEMS ALLEN. ALLEN I
WAS SO. WELL I WAS ALIVE WE'RE
SORRY PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE WIENER. WE ARE ALL RIGHT
GERMAN A BILL IS OUT FIFTEEN
ZERO. OKAY WITH THAT. BOOK WE
GOT TWO MORE I'M PRETTY MORE.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED BY MEMBERS
ARE OPEN UP THE ROLL CALL ON A.
B. OR SORRY ON FILE ITEM TWO AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
BARGES. NIELSEN WIENER. WHERE
ARE. THAT'S TWENTY TWO GERMAN
WELL THE TO THE BILLS OUT. OKAY
MEMBERS NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
FOR AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
ABSENT MEMBER AYE WIENER. ALL
RIGHT LEADER ALL RIGHT GERMAN
THAT'S OUT FIFTEEN ZERO BILLS
OUT FIFTEEN ZERO. AND LAST BILL
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY TWENTY TWENTY A BY SOME
MEMBER ARE WE ARE CURRY. ABSENT
MEMBERS BARGES. JONES NIELSEN
WIENER WIENER HI. THAT'S
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO GERMAN BILLS
OUT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE TODAY I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO. THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE MODERATOR-
DID AN OUTSTANDING JOB MONDAY-
MOVIE THIS MEETING ALONG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR- IT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE-COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED-
ARBIL HEARING AGENDA WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. BAR
COMPX. MICHELLE OKAY THAT IS
THE ONLY A- WISEMAN.
ENGINE
ANYTHING ON THE INFORMATION
PORTION I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING
THE PHARMACY YEAH I. IN THE
MORNING GALLERIA. IF YOU CAN. I
DON'T THINK MEAN FOR THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOUNG AND THE AT THE
END OF NUMBER YOU CAN THIS
THINKING ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
THAT OF MY.
GOOD MORNING I'M
SENATOR BILL DODD CHAIRMAN OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION. TODAY
WE WILL HOLDING INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON SIX TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT. THIS INCLUDES CONTACT
WITH I OWN MORE CHALLENGE. PUSH
AT THE SHINGLE SPRINGS TO LOWER
IT TO THE RIVER. FOR THOSE OF
YOU UNFAMILIAR WITH THE
SENATE'S PROCEDURE THE
ESTABLISH POLICY ALLOWS FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THE
DETAILS OF THE COMPACT TO BE
FOLLOWED BY A VOTE. ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. NO VOTE WILL BE
TAKEN HERE TODAY. THE VEHICLE
FOR RATIFICATION FOR ALL SIX
CONTACTS WILL BE S. B. EIGHT
SIX NINE. THAT'S AUTHOR THAT
BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
AGREED TO CO AUTHOR THAT
LEGISLATION. IT WILL BE AMENDED
NEXT WEEK AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO PRESENTING THAT BILL
ON THE SENATE FLOOR. IN THE
COMING WEEKS. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THESE
CONTACTS MERE THE MANY RECENT
COMPACTS THAT HAVE COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. THIS INCLUDES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
LANGUAGE LABOR PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW WORKERS TO UNIONIZE.
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW OFF
RESERVATION MITIGATION AND
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES TRIBES
TO FOLLOW STATE LAW. RELATED TO
MINIMUM WAGE. I KNOW MANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE THE WHOLE I
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT IN MAKING SURE THE
LANGUAGE IS INCLUDED. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL SIX TRIBAL
CHAIRS FOR AGREEING TO THESE
PROVISIONS IN THEIR CONTACTS. I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT NORMALLY
WE WOULD DO EACH CONTACT
INDIVIDUALLY. BUT BECAUSE OF
TIME CONSTRAINTS AND FACILITATE
THE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
PRESENTERS WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH IN A NAY MARK TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER FOR
GOVERNOR THE SON WHO PRESENT ON
ALL SIX CONTACTS FIRST. SHE
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY EACH TRIBAL
CHAIR IN ALPHABET ALPHABETICAL
ORDER BEGINNING WITH I OWN IN
FINISHING. WITH TO THE RIVER.
THAT WILL BE FOLLOWED BY JACK
RUBIN FROM UNITED HERE AND
WE'LL FINISH OFF WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PURCHASE OF A TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IN L. NELSON NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR IN THE
ACCESS CODE. IS. SEVEN ZERO
ZERO EIGHT THREE SIX ONE LET ME
REPEAT THAT. 844-291-6364 IS
THE NUMBER. IN THE PASSCODE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN ZERO ZERO
EIGHT THREE SIX ONE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT I MISS THE
MARKETS ON THE ZOOM CONFERENCE
CALL. MODERATOR IF WE CAN GET
HONOR- GET HER ON VIDEO SO WE
CAN BEGIN. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. HOW GOOD MORNING SHERMAN
DIED AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME IS ANTHONY MARK AND I AM
THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER. THEY
ASKED TODAY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF ALL SIX CO
CONTACTED THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
NEGOTIATED. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK EACH OF THE
CHAIRPERSONS OF THE TRIBES
WHOSE CONTACT WE'RE JUST
COMPACTS WE ARE DISCUSSING
TODAY THEIR COMMITMENT TO
NEGOTIATION THROUGH A PANDEMIC
AND DEEPALI I'M DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION IN A DIFFICULT
TIME. AFTER MANY MONTHS AND IN
SOME CASES MANY YEARS OF
NEGOTIATION ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE TABLE I WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO BEING ON THE SAME
SIDE OF THE TABLE AND I
TESTIFYING TOGETHER. IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE ARE NOT THE
TIMES THAT WE LIVE IN. THE
GOVERNOR HAS NEGOTIATED AND
SIGNED SIX NEW TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT THESE CONTACTS
ARE BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
I. OWN BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS.
THE MORE TOWN RANCHERIA OF MY
DO INDIANS A SCAN TYPE BANDS OF
NO MACHI INDIANS SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS
THE TOLOWA DEE NI NATION AND
THE TO THE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE
OF CALIFORNIA. EACH OF THESE
COMPLEXES INDIVIDUALLY
NEGOTIATED AND IS UNIQUE TO
EACH TRIBE BUT HE CORE GOALS
OF SUPPORTING STRONG SELF
SUFFICIENT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
IN FUNDING ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES TRIBAL CITIZENS THE
REVENUES GENERATED THROUGH
THEIR CASINOS. THE I. OWN
COMPACT IS THE FIRST CONTACT
FOR THE TRIBE WHICH WILL
FACILITATE A NEW REVENUE STREAM
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNMENT AND
GOVERNMENT SERVICES THE MORE
TOWN DISCONTENT AND HOLLOW
COMPACTS WERE NEGOTIATED AHEAD
OF THEIR EXPIRING NINETEEN
NINETY NINE COMPACT. ALLOWING
THEM TO CONTINUE GAINING THE
SHINGLE SPRINGS CONTACTUS
RENEGOTIATED TO UPDATE THE
TERMS FROM ITS TWENTY TWELVE
CONTACTS TO ALIGN WITH MORE
MODERN COMPACTS THE TO THE
RIVER CONTACT WAS RENEGOTIATED
TO ADDRESS THE TRIBE'S NEW
PARCEL OF GAINING LAND. TO THE
RIVERS NEW PARCEL IS SUBJECT TO
WHAT IS CALLED A TWO PART
DETERMINATION OR SECRETARIAL
PROCEDURES. THIS IS THE PROCESS
SET FORTH IN THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT THAT ALLOWS THE
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR TO
TAKE LAND INTO TRUST. FOR
GAMING ACQUIRED AFTER NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT IF THE TRIBE GOES
THROUGH A PROCESS BY WHICH THE
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
DETERMINES. THE TAKING THIS
LAND INTO TRUST WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE TRIBE AND NOT
DETRIMENTAL TO THE SOUNDING
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. THE
SECRETARY DETERMINED THAT THIS
WAS INDEED THE CASE. AND
REQUESTED THAT THE GOVERNOR
CONCUR WITH HIS DETERMINATION.
AFTER EXTENSIVE REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR CONCURRED WITH THIS
DECISION BECAUSE OF THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS FOR THE TRIBE
AND ITS MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. ECONOMIC
PROVISIONS OF EACH CONTACT SEEK
TO ADDRESS THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. SAYS AND MARKET
EACH TRIBE ON MAKING SURE TO
NOT DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT
ANYONE TRY WHEN LOOKING AT THE
UNIVERSE COMPAQ'S. COURSE OF
THIS APPROACH WAS ENSURING THAT
EACH TRIBE IS THE PRIMARY
BENEFICIARY OF THE FACILITY I
DID TENDED BY THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT. AND THAT THE
CONTACTS PROVIDED FOR THE FAIR
REIMBURSEMENT THE STATE
REGULATORY COSTS IS SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND OR STF AS
WELL THE REVENUE SHARING WITH
LIMITED AND NON GAMING TRIBES
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
AND THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT
FUNDS. THE I. OWN CONTACT WITH
A MAXIMUM OF TWELVE HUNDRED
DEVICES HE'S PROGRAM STF AND
PAYS NO REVENUE SHARING FUNDS.
THE MARKET TOWN CONTACT HAS A
MAXIMUM OF TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DEVICES. AS
PRO RATA STF HAS NO SHARING UP
TO TWELVE DEVICES. 6% NOW WHEN
WITH 80% CREDITS BETWEEN
TWELVE. HUNDRED ONE AND
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DEVICES AND 6%
NOT WINDY 65% CREDITS FROM
EIGHT HUNDRED. AND WANTED TO
YOUR FIFTY DEVICE. TO CONTACT
THE MAX OF TWO THOUSAND. WITH
PRO RATA STA. NO REVENUE SHE UP
TO TALK HUNDRED. AND SEE
PERCENT WIN SEVENTY CRY FROM
HUNDRED ONE A TWO TWO THOUSAND
DEVICES. SHE GOES BRING COMPACT
AT THE MAXIMUM OF TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES THE 6% NOT
WIN 65% CREDITS UP TO TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY. AND
DEVICES AND 6% NOT WIND 6%
CREDITS FROM TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE DEVICES UP TO
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES. IT
ALSO ELIMINATES ALL GENERAL
FUND PAYMENTS BY THE TRIED.
PAYMENTS TO THE GENERAL FUND
WERE FOUND TO BE AN ILLEGAL TAX
BY FEDERAL COURTS AND NO OTHER
TRIBES PAY ONGOING FEDERAL
FUNDS. HELLO IS A MAXIMUM OF
TWO THOUSAND DEVICES WITH PRO
RATA STF NO REVENUE SHARING UP
TO TWELVE HUNDRED DEVICES. 6%
NOT WIN WITH 70% CREDITS FROM
TWELVE HUNDRED AND ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND DEVICES THE TO THE
RIVER COMPACT AS A MAXIMUM OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES.
BUT PRO RATA STF 6% THAT WENT
WITH A 100% CREDITS UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED DEVICES 6% NOT
WIN WITH EIGHTY CREDITS BETWEEN
TWELVE HUNDRED ONE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DEVICES. AND 6% THAT
WENT WITH 60% CREDITS BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED ONE DEVICES
AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DEVICES. THE CREDITS AGAINST
REVENUE SHARING PAYMENTS. THERE
WERE PRIOR MENTION OUR AGREED
UPON AS MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
USES OF FUNDING. ROOTING FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSING HEALTHCARE
AND OTHER INVESTMENTS IN THIS
RUNNING COMMUNITY AND THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THIS COMPACT
INCLUDING TERMS RELATING TO
LICENSING REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THAT
THE CABAZON COMPACTS THAT WAS
RATIFIED BY THIS BODY LAST YEAR.
THE SUBSTANTIAL SIMILARITY
INCLUDES PROTECTIONS AGAINST
WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT PROVISIONS TO ADOPT
AND COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT
INCLUSION OF THE STATE'S
MINIMUM WAGE RATES. RIDES WILL
ADOPT THE STANDARD TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE CONTACTS
ALSO INCLUDE PROVISIONS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IN
MITIGATION BUT LESS INTENSIVE
PROP PROCESS EASE IF THE TRIBE
OPERATES UNDER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY DEVICES. ACTIVE OF THE
DEVICE COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL
PROVISIONS REQUIRE THAT A HEAD
OF ANY PROJECT THE TRIBE MUST
ANALYZE AND DOCUMENT OFFERS A
REACHING IMPACTS. PROVIDE FOR A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD AND COME
TO A MITIGATION AGREEMENT WITH
THE LOCAL OR STATE GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I AM HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. ANY QUESTIONS.
AB MISTAKE I DO I CAN YOU GO A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON HOW THESE
CREDITS WORK IN WHAT THE
THINKING IS BEHIND THOSE. IS
THE IDEA TO TRY TO KEEP MOST
THE REVENUE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE JUST WHAT WHAT
IS THE APPROACHED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT
QUESTION GERMAN DOT. SO YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
ONE OF OUR GREATEST PRIORITIES
HERE IS REVENUE SHARING WITH
LIMITED AND NON GAMING TRIBES
AND SO. WE ARE SOMEWHAT
PROTECTIVE OF THAT BUT IN
RECOGNIZING THAT TRIBES
CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH AND SHE
ABOVE AND BEYOND. SORT OF
REGULAR GOVERNMENT SERVICES IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES- AS WELL
AS- YOU KNOW CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND- FOR
EXAMPLE ALL DAY I JUST OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD A SHINGLE
SPRINGS I KNOW. HAS WHITE WATER
RESCUE TEAM THE ONLY ONE IN THE
AREA. AND YOU KNOW. DISCONTENT
INVESTS IN THE LOCAL SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW TULE RIVER
HAS ITS OWN SCHOOL AS ITS OWN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND IS
REVIVING LANGUAGES- I MEAN ALL
OF THE TRIBES ARE YOU KNOW HAVE
BEEN SORT OF OPERATING THESE
AMAZING PROGRAMS. AND SO THE
IDEA IS TO GIVE CREDIT OFF OF
THOSE REVENUE SHARING PAYMENTS.
FOR THE SORT OF MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL INVESTMENTS AND-
THEN THE GOAL OF THIS IS NOT
ONLY TO KIND OF RECOGNIZE
WHETHER THE AMAZING THINGS THAT
ALL OF THE TRIBES ARE DOING.
BUT ALSO TO KIND OF INCENTIVIZE
THAT CONTINUED LOCAL INVESTMENT
AND SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
PROCESS THAT HAPPENS IS. THE
TRIBE KIND OF SUBMITS TO THE
STATE YOU KNOW HERE'S WHAT WE
ARE PLANNING ON DOING UNDER THE
TERMS OF THE COMPACT WE REVIEW
IT WE DISCUSS IT SOMETIMES WE
NEED MORE INFORMATION USUALLY
IT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
AND THEN WE SAY GREAT THE- GOES
AHEAD AND- YOU KNOW SPENDS THAT
THOSE FUNDS AND THEN AT THE END
OF THE YEAR. THERE'S SORT OF A
AN ACCOUNTING PROCESS WHERE
THEY SAY HERE'S WHAT WE SPEND
ALL OF THE FUNDS ON YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THAT OBVIOUSLY
CHANGES OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR- AND THEN WE HAVE SORT OF
A RECONCILIATION PROCESS AND
THEN BACK TO MOUNT. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO PAY TO THE STATE'S OF
THE FUNDS NEVER COME TO THE
STATE AT ALL IT STAYS WITH THE
TRIBE IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
WE THINK THIS HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY KIND OF BENEFICIAL.
ASPECT TO THESE COMPACT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS THE MARK ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I'VE SEEN NONE- NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO SERRA DISCHI- TRIBAL
CHAIR FOR THE I. OWN BAD I
BELIEVE SHE'S HERE IN THE
GALLERY CHAIRWOMAN WELCOME.
THANK YOU. I COULD MORNING
CHAIRMAN DODD TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M SCARED THAT
FUTURE WON'T FOR THE I AM THE
ENEMY WALK INDIANS. I'LL BE
HALF OF THE TRIBE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND I'LL DO MY BEST TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF. I THE I AM IN A
ME WALK INDIANS IS LOCATED IN
AMADOR COUNTY NOT TOO FAR FROM
HERE. AND IT'S AN AREA THAT WE
HAVE CALLED HOME FOR THOUSANDS
OF YEARS. WITHIN ENROLLED
MEMBERSHIP OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY INDIVIDUALS. WE
ARE BY FAR THE LARGEST TRIBE IN
OUR REGION. AND ANNA MENTIONED
WE ARE PRESENTLY THE ONLY TRIBE
WITH THE COMPACT BEFORE YOU
TODAY. THAT IS NOT INVOLVED IN
GAMING. LIKE SO MANY OF OUR
SISTER TRIBAL NATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA OUR HISTORY IS
PRETTY TRAGIC. INVOLVING A
CENTURY LONG EFFORT TO RESTORE
A GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE UNITED
STATES. AND TO SECURE OUR
HOMELAND CAPABLE OF SUPPORTING
OUR GOVERNMENT AND OUR
POPULATION. I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF
SEVERAL GENERATIONS OF TRIBAL
LEADERS AND CITIZENS. WE'RE
ABLE TO RESTORE THAT GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. AND JUST
ON MARCH TWENTIETH OF THIS YEAR
WE RESTORED OUR VERY FIRST
LANCER TRUST IN AMADOR COUNTY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ACRES RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF THE CITY OF PLYMOUTH.
OF COURSE OUR EFFORTS FOR TO
REGAIN OUR RECOGNITION AND TO
RESTORE LOCAL HOMELAND HAVE NOT
COME WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT COST.
HIGH PROPERTY VALUES IN OUR
AREA COMBINED WITH COST TO
UNDERGO THE FEDERAL FEE TO
TRUST PROCESS. AS WELL AS THE
YEARS OF LITIGATION DEFENDING
ARE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
STATUS. AND OUR RIGHT TO
RESTORE LAND BASED. HAVE LEFT
US WITH CONSIDERABLE DEBT.
FURTHER THE LACK OF A LAND
BASED AND FIND IN HAVE
SUFFICIENTLY CONSTRAINED OUR
EFFORTS TO DEVELOP CRITICAL
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES. TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR CITIZENS.
TRIBAL GAMING QUITE FRANKLY. IS
OUR ONLY MEANS OF MEETING THESE
OBLIGATIONS AND TO BEGINNING TO
BUILD A ROBUST IN SUPPORT OF
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT FOR OUR
PEOPLE. TODAY I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT OUR
RECENTLY NEGOTIATED AND AGAIN
VERY FIRST TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT. SO WE ARE THE ONLY
TRIED THAT IT IS NOT PRESENTLY
ENGAGED IN GAMING WE ARE NOT
STRANGERS TO THE POSITIVE
IMPACTS TRIBAL GAMING HAS ON
THE COMMUNITY IT VASTLY CHANGES
THE ECONOMIC CLIMATE NOT ONLY
ON BUT AROUND TRIBAL LANDS. IT
CREATES JOBS GENERATES
SECONDARY REVENUE THAT BENEFITS
INDIAN COUNTRY AND OUR
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
REVENUE FROM GAMING OPERATIONS
ALLOWS TRIED TO TRIED TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
CITIZENS. SECURE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES PROTECT CULTURAL
RESOURCES PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS AND ASSIST OUR NON TRIBAL
NEIGHBORS TO GRANT OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. THESE ARE
PRECISELY THE SAME GOALS WE
HAVE WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE. AS A
RESULT OF OUR OWN GAMING
OPERATIONS. JUST NOTE IN A
COUPLE OF THE THINGS THAT ANNA
NOTED FR YOU ABOUT OUR
CONTACT. IT AUTHORIZES UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED CLASS THREE
GAMING MACHINES AS WELL AS
OTHER FORMS OF GAMING. IT
THAT'S FOR THE MEDIAN FOR
CONSUMER AND EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS. CONTAINS VIGOROUS
PROVISIONS FOR THE MITIGATION
OF OFF RESERVATION IMPACTS OF
THE GAMING FACILITY. IT
DEMONSTRATES THIS TRIBE STRONG
COMMITMENT TO REVENUE SHARING
THROUGH THE R. S. T. F. AND THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUNDED
FUTURE YEARS. FUNDS IN FACT
PROVIDED MY TRIBE WITH VALUABLE
RESOURCES- FOR MANY YEARS. IT
REFLECTS THE TRIBES PLEDGE TO
COMMUTE TO SUPPORT INVOLVEMENT
IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. FOR
IMPROVED EMERGENCY SERVICES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT ALL DESIGNED TO
BENEFIT NOT ONLY TO TRY BUT
AMADOR COUNTY AS A WHOLE. AND
OF COURSE. THE COMP PROVIDE THE
TRIBE WITH THE MEANS OF
GENERATING REVENUE THAT WE CAN
USE TO ESTABLISH LONG TERM
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY. AND
PROSPERITY FOR OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND OUR CITIZENS.
GIVEN OPERATIONS WILL GENERATE
REVENUE TO SUPPORT OUR SOCIAL
EACH EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
HOUSING HEALTHCARE PRESERVATION%
OF CULTURE RESOURCES ALL THINGS
THAT WE STILL STRUGGLE TO
MAINTAIN. IT'S A REALLY REALLY
EXCITING TIME FOR US. I LIKE TO
THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE
AND IN PARTICULAR AND IN A MARK
FOR HER PROFESSIONALISM. AND
INTEGRITY AS WE WORK TO COME TO
AGREEMENT ON THE CONTACT AS
WELL AS ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE WHO WORKED HARD IN
HELPING TO BRING OUR CONTACT
HOME. AND ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TODAY AND URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT OUR CONTACT.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF WHAT I
HOPE TO BE MANY DISCUSSIONS
WITH MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
AS WE WORK TO DEVELOP
PROSPEROUS GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE TRIBE IN THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SAYING THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE A
PERSON TODAY. WHAT SORRY.
CENTER JUST JUST JUST A QUICKER
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I FOUND IT VERY
HELPFUL I KNOW THAT- CREATING A
CONTACT IS NOT AN EASY PROCESS
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING THIS WENT
VERY WELL YEAH I'M I'M GLAD
THAT WORKING WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OFFICIATE
THIS AND- THANK YOU FOR ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I AM PROUD TO
REPRESENT AMADOR COUNTY AND-
ALL YOUR TRAVEL REGION. THANK
YOU SEVERAL WILK YES- THANK YOU
CHAIR DIED- BY TWO LOOKING
FORWARD TO VOTING FOR THIS ON
THE FLOOR- WHEN I KNOW WHAT THE
TRIBE I WAS JUST SO IMPRESSED
WITH THEIR DETERMINATION TO
COME TO THE POINT THAT THEY ARE
TODAY ARE THEY HAVE EXCITED
ECONOMIC POSITION WITH
STRATEGIC PARTNERS IN THE
REGION AND THIS IS NOT ONLY
IS GOING TO END IT IS GOING TO
BENEFIT THE ENTIRE REGION AND
WHEN WE DO THESE CONTACTS WERE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR A WIN WINS
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
WIN WIN. FOR THE TRIBE FOR THE
REGION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER WILL CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU I'M AND MISTER
CHAIR. I ALSO WANT TO THANK-
EVAN. THE LADY FOR THE
PRESENTATION I THINK IT'S
REALLY VALUABLE WHEN THEY HAVE
A VISION TO SUPPORT NOT ONLY
EDUCATION BUT I KNOW I'LL I
HEARD OR STATE THAT THEY WANNA
COMMIT TO PUTTING FINDING UNTIL
EMERGENCY INFRASTRUCTURE AND I
KNOW HOW CRITICAL IT IS FOR
LOCAL. CITIES AS A FORMER
COUNCIL MEMBER I KNEW THAT THAT
WAS THE BIGGEST PART OF OUR
BUDGET AND I'VE SEEN IT ALL
ACROSS THE STATE THE SUPPORT TO
THE NEIGHBORING CITY SO I'M
ALSO VERY ENCOURAGED BY THIS
PRESENTATION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
OTHER PRODUCTS. SAYING THAT
THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN THANK YOU.
I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO BENJAMIN
CLARK CHAIR OF THE MOORTOWN
RANCHERIA I BELIEVE HE IS ON
THE CO HOSTS LIVE MODERATOR IF
WE GET HIM ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
ARE YOU ON ARE YOU READY. HE HE
HE HE. MARKET YOUR BACKGROUND.
YEAH I DON'T HAVE ANY. OKAY IN
YOUR NAME NOW. WE COULD HEAR
YOU GO AHEAD HELLO. YES
CHAIRMAN THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. FROM OUR
MILITARY MANY MEMBER. YOUR I AM
BENJAMIN CARPETRIGHT ARE I'M
AROUND THREE OF MY. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TO
PROVIDE REMARKS. CONTACT BEFORE
YOU TODAY RECORD A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK BOTH THE STATE
AND TRIBAL LEADERS. AND
COMPLETED THE PROCESS LESS THAN
TWO TWO WEEKS AGO. WE WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS
CHIEF NEGOTIATOR ANTHONY MARK
AND HER STAFF FOR DEVOTING THE
TIME EVEN DURING THE DIFFICULT
TO USE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. TO COLLABORATORY
ASSEMBLY WORK THROUGH A NUMBER
OF ISSUES INTEL WE SUCCESSFULLY
REACHING AGREEMENT. GAMING HAS
BEEN A KEY TO THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE TOWN
RANCHERIA OF MY DO INDIANS FOR
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW.
WE ARE PROUD OF OUR FEATHER
FALLS CASINO AND ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO VISIT. AS INCREASING
PRESSURE. ON OUR ECONOMIC
VIABILITY. FROM COMPETING
TRIBAL CASINOS- COBIT INDUCED
SHUT DOWN AND IT FLOWING
ECONOMY. OUR GOAL IN ENTERING
INTO THIS COMPACT IT PROVIDES
FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR TRIBE
THAT CERTAINTY IS IMPORTANT AS
WE STRIVE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. IN THE COMMUNITY
AND MAINTAIN THE CONTINUATION
SAFE OPERATION OF ECONOMIC
ENTERPRISES THAT HAVE BECOME
CRUCIAL TO TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. THE NEW
COMPACT WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SOCIAL EDUCATIONAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC PROGRAMS. AND OTHER
SERVICES TO TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THESE
SERVICES ACTUALLY BECOME A
CENTRAL DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
MORE DOWN RANCHERIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THE CONTACT
WITH THE STATE BE APPROVED.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS I
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS.
SUTTER NIELSEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT. THE MORE TOWN
RANCHERIA AND THE CHAIRMAN.
THEY'VE HAD SOME CHALLENGES
THEY GO THROUGH OVER A NUMBER
OF YEARS. AND INDEED THERE HAS
BEEN SOME COMPETITIVE ISSUES.
AND THEY WORK THAT OUT AMONGST
NEIGHBORING TRIBES. AND IN
THEIR OWN. AND THEY PRESENT
THEMSELVES NOW I THINK WITH THE
SECURE ABILITY. TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC. TO PROVIDE NEEDS AND
ONE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO EMPHASIZE ABOUT
ALL OF THE TRIBES. PART OF OUR
ANALYSIS HERE OF NOTES THAT
THESE TRIBAL COMPACTS DON'T IN
YOUR MUCH TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. H. N. I
WILL ARGUE THAT MAYBE AND TO
THEMSELVES THEY DO NOT. BUT I
AM VERY FAMILIAR OVER MANY
DECADES OF THE GENEROSITY. OF
OUR TRIBES TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IN TIMES OF CRISES. AND SORT OF
UNFORTUNATE AREA THE NORTH
STATE FOR SENATE DISTRICT WE
END UP HAVING A LOT OF REAL
CHALLENGES. AND THE TRIBES IN
THE AREA ARE ALWAYS RIGHT THERE
FOR US. AND FOR THE CITIZENS IN
THE AREAS THAT THEY SERVE. WHO
ARE THEIR PATRONS. AND I WANT
TO COMPLIMENT HIM ON THAT. IT
IS TO THE CREDIT. OF THESE
TRIBES THEIR BENEVOLENCE. AND
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THESE
CONTACTS TO BE APPROVED. THANK
YOU SAID. I THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN CLARKE- I APPRECIATE
YOU- TESTIFYING TODAY-
CONGRATULATIONS ON- YOU KNOW
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A TRUE
ALLY HYDRATE CHAIR OF THE PAY
SCANT- BAD I BELIEVE HE'S
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE CO HOST
LINES WELL. MODERATOR IF WE CAN
GET HIM ON THE PHONE. GERMAN
ALL A HUNDRED ARE YOU THERE.
MODERATOR THE SHOW THAT WE HAVE
CHAIRMAN ON THE LINE. NO SIR I
DO NOT. OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO.
MOVED THROUGH THE SPEAKERS AT
THE CHAIRMAN WANTS TO- TESTIFY
AT THE END WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM. SPEAK AT
THAT TIME. SO WITH THAT- WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO SHE OR BUDGET
HERE FROM BUT THE CHAIR OF THE
SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF REGINA
PLAY ARE THAT SHE WILL BE USING
THE COASTLINE AS WELL. GERMAN
CHOIR ARE YOU ON THE LINE. SURE
WOULD GOOD MORNING YES I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS REGINA QUICK LEARNER
AND THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS GRAYSON FOREMOST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
DODD AND GEO COMMITTEE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK GOVERNOR NEW
SEMANA NAME MARK FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK AB. AND HIS GET HIS
CONTACT THROUGH AND THANK YOU
FOR THE HONOR WHERE HONOR
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRIDENT MANY CONTACT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I CANNOT EXPLAIN
TO YOU THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
SEMANTIC CONTACT FOR ARCHIVE IT
FINALLY BRINGS THE MEASURE OF.
THE SHINGLES AND WHICH SIMPLY
THINK AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD IN
ANY MARKET THAT IS COMING
INCREASINGLY COMPETITIVE THIS
AMENDMENT CONTACTED SHE THOUGHT
HE LOOKS PRUDENT MAN HAS FACED
MORE OBSTACLES THAN MOST
CALIFORNIA TRIED IN THE EFFORT
TO ESTABLISH BEANIE. THIS IS
TRUE BECAUSE OUR RESERVATION
WAS LANDLOCKED IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES WITH THE ALIGNMENT OF
AN I. G. A CASE HIGHWAY BUT THE
RATHER THAT LACK ANY FORM OF
PUBLIC ACCESS. AT THAT TIME WE-
EXCHANGES THOUSAND EIGHT OTHER
WERE FINALLY ABLE TO. YOUR
ABILITY. CAL I THINK YOU PUBLIC.
OVER THE- IF IT CITED INTO
CONNECTING OUR RECORD FOR
HIGHWAYS. AS A RESULT WE ABLE
TO BRAND HOW CASINO SUCCESSFUL
WELL RIGHT AND WINNING GAMING.
CENTER TIME WE HAVE. STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR NEIGHBOR
AS WELL LOCAL AND SERVED AGENCY
WE HAVE DEVELOPED A HEALTH
CLINIC THAT SERVES NATIVE AND
NON NATIVE PEOPLE THROUGHOUT EL
DORADO COUNTY AND THROUGH A
VERY GENEROUS AND WILL YOU BE
TREATED OVER TEN MILLION JUST
COUNTY GOVERNMENT EVERY YEAR
BOTH OF THIS MONEY IS FREE FOR
THE COUNTY TO YOU THAT.
EXPRESSION OF THE WORD CRISIS
ANY TELLING WE WERE FORCED TO
ON. ANSWER MAY DEBT AND THE
CALL WITH OWNERS NATURE BUT I
NATIONAL TERM WITH. WE AFTER
PAGE IF YOU OF OUR NEXT GAME
REVENUE. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE GOVERNOR HELP THE
PRIVATE A MINUTE THAT PROVIDE
ERROR. AT LEAST PART TIME
PERIOD. THIS ENABLED US TO OFF
OUR DEBT AND BEGIN BENEFIT FROM
OUR GAMING. WITH THIS NO LIKE
OTHER NATHAN THOSE ARE. TERMS
CAN'T CONTINUE BRINGING OUR
CONTACT IN LINE OTHER WILL
CONTACT IF RATIFIED BY THE
LATEST. BUT SHE LOOKED BRING NO
OPERATED THEY CAN'T FIND OUT
DESERVE NOW. IS A MEMORABLE
ALSO ENABLE US TO YOU CONTACT
CRITICS TO SUPPORT GOOD AND
WORTHY CAUSES THAT BENEFIT
NATIVE PEOPLE AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AMONG THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE CAN NOW
HARNESS APART ARE ENHANCED
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION.
BASIC HOUSING FOR THOSE IN NEED
AND. OUR. THAT'S SEEING NONE
IRATE- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND EFFORT THAT GOES INTO
THESE CONTACTS I WOULD- AB.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN TO ASK YOU- IF
YOU- COULD BABY DETAIL A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT- SB TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND COUNTIES IS. IS KEY IS.
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING- AND PERHAPS
YOU COULD DETAIL COUPLE THINGS
THAT- YOU'RE DOING IN THE
COMMUNITY. EVERY FIRST OF ALL
WE CAN LEAST HAVE A FIRE WE
HELD THEM PART OF THAT MONEY
ALL GOES WAY IN AND A TWO LANE
FOR THE COUNTY WE ALL HELPED
WITH A LOT AND I UNDER AND I
SORRY UNDER SERVICE NOT A ARE
UNDER LONG COURSE WE HAVE READ.
TRANSPORTATION. WE ALSO PLAN
GET READY SPEAKS AND THE BOYS
GIRLS CLUB HOTEL CAL ANDWE'RE
JUST TO NAME A FEW THE ONES
THAT DO HAVE AND WE ALL HELP
MORE COMMUNITY WHICH THE SAME
OLD BUT ALL AND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT'S AMAZING CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I JUST
VERY QUICKLY WANTED TO STOP
HIGHLIGHTED WHAT TREMENDOUS
BOMB STATED THAT TEN MILLION I
THINK IN GENERAL I WANT TO
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
CREATED AND I WANNA IN GENERAL
NOT NECESSARY ABOUT THIS
COMPACT BUT ALL COMPACTS IN
GENERAL I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE BECAUSE SOME OF MY
COMMUNITIES. STUDENTS HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM SUCH THEIR
GENEROSITY NOT ONLY DO THEY
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES BUT
THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
WAY TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
IN FOR EXAMPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
SO THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO FIND A
COUPLE OF. OF PROJECTS IN MY
SCHOOL SINCIL AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND DIE AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE GONE
BEYOND OUR BORDERS TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S NOT ONLY BENEFITS
DELTA I'M- BUT TO THE
SURROUNDING AREAS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU RUBIO
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR WOMAN WE
WILL NOW HEAR FROM LEON
MCCALLUM. A CHAIR OF THE TO LOW
IDEATION I BELIEVE SHE IS ON
THE COAST LINE AS WALMART
RAIDER IF WE CAN. GET HER ON
THE LINE PLEASE. WE ENCOUNTER
CHAIRPERSON OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION- WE ARE
LOCATED IN THE HEART COUNTY WE
HAVE ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN OLD BEVERAGE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. OUR THANK
SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFFERS. THE TIME THE ON GOING
NINETEEN. CHECKER TRIED TO CALL
HIS. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
REQUIRE AND- BOOKS FOR THEIR
AND THEIR ACCORDING TO WA DAE
NATION AND CHANGED A NEW
COMPACT THAT WILL FURTHER
ENABLE THE TRIBE. ALSO SPEECH
ENTERTAINER THIRTY BETTER THE
LIVES OF NOT ONLY NUMBER. BUT
THAT AND THE LINE IN THE
SURROUNDINGCOMMUNITY AND
REGION. I HEARD. FIRED NUMEROUS
PRO AND COMMUNITY OR YOU. OUR
ACCORDING TO THE TRIBES IN
OPERATION. FIFTEEN MARCH AND
RELATED. FOR THE RECORD I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK GOVERNOR IN HE
ANTHONY MARK CAN GET ON THE
GOVERNOR HIGHER. CHANGE FOR
THEIR TO WORKING WITH TO TRY ON
THE CONTACT. THIS SHARE OKAY.
LOS MARCH WE HAVE. NEW OR
LETTERS THAT WERE EXCHANGED
OKAY SEVENTH. EIGHT SUPPORT ON
THE DAY COUNTY. SHARES MAN
LOCAL TRY. AND COUNTY. WE'RE
ACTUALLY OUT. AFTER THEIR
INTEREST OF THOSE D. SIX. IF
YOU HAVE ANY PLEASE LET ME KNOW
AND I'M BE PROBABLY. ANSWER
THEM AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE ORDER AND- THANK
YOU- MANAGER YOU KNOW I DID
HAVE A QUESTION- YOU CURRENTLY
OPERATE LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SLOT MACHINES AND- ARE
THUS CONSIDERED A LIMITED
GAMING TRIBE. ARE THERE PLANS
FOR THE TRIBE TO OPERATE MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MACHINES AND IF SO WHEN DO YOU
EXPECT THAT EXPANSION
BUREAUCRAT. HI CANNOT LOOK AT
EXTREMELY HARDWORKING AND- OKAY
WELL ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE
CHAIRWOMAN C. NONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND SUCCESS ON THIS IS YEAH
THIS WILL BE VOTED ON ON THE
SENATE FLOOR IN THE NEXT- WEEK
OR SO THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN
WE'RE GONNA MOVED OUT TO- NEIL.
BYRON SHARE THE TULE RIVER
INDIAN TRIBE HE SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE VIA ZOOM. MARIN IF WE
BRING THE CHAIRMAN. ORDING
MORNING TURNED OUT THANK YOU
AND THAT ALSO THANK YOU TO VICE
CHAIRMAN WILL GET THE OTHER
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THE L.
BROWN AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
TULE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE IS AN
HONOR TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE TRIBE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIX NINE A
BILL THAT WOULD RATIFY THE
GAMING COMPACT INTRODUCED INTO
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE TRIBE WHICH WAS
EXECUTED ON AUGUST THIRD TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ANNONAY MARC IN THE
GOVERNOR AND ALL OF THEIR STAFF
WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY WITH THE
TRIBE IN OUR STAFF TO GET THIS
ACCOMPLISHED THE BEGIN I WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
BRIEF BACKGROUND OF THE TRIBE
AND ITS MEMBERSHIP GOVERNMENT
AND GAMING OPERATIONS THE TRIBE
IS OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE
WITH ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX MEMBERS AND SITUATED
ON THE TULE RIVER INDIAN
RESERVATION TULARE COUNTY
RESERVATION CONSIST OF
550-003-0090 SIX ACRES. AND IS
LOCATED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
MILES FROM THE CITY AFFORDABLE
TULARE COUNTY THE TROUBLE
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES A FULL
RANGE OF SERVICES TO ITS
MEMBERSHIP WHICH INCLUDES
EDUCATION HEALTH HOUSING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRE TRIBAL COURT
SERVICES AMBULANCE SERVICE
PUBLIC UTILITIES NATURAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE SERVICE WE ALSO.
PROVIDE AN ELDER CENTER AND OF.
CENTER TO THE FOR THOSE MEMBERS
THE TRIBE HAS WORKED. TERRACE
THE TO THE- OF LIFE FOR TRIBAL
MEMBERS HAVE SUFFERED FROM A
HISTORY OF FORCED REMOVAL. AND
DISPOSITION TRIBAL LANDS AND
RESOURCES ALTHOUGH ON
RESERVATIONS SOCIAL ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS HAVE IMPROVED OVER
TIME. RESIDENTS CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
FOR APPROXIMATELY 40% ON
RESERVATION. AND APPROXIMATELY
44% OF TRIBAL MEMBERS LIVE IN
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE NEAR OR
BELOW THE POVERTY LINE.
ADDITIONALLY MANY MEMBERS DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY DUE TO SEVERE
SHORTAGES ON THE RESERVATION.
AS A RESULT OF WATER SHORTAGES
THE TRIBE HAD TO PLACE A
MORATORIUM ON BUILDING NEW
STRUCTURES ON THE RESERVATION.
INCLUDING TRIBAL HOUSING EVEN
THOUGH THE TRIBE HAS A HOUSING
WAITING LIST OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED FAMILIES AT THIS TIME.
THE TRIBES EXISTING CASINOS
LOCATED ON THE RESERVATION BUT
DUE TO GROWING TRIBAL
POPULATION INCREASED DEMAND FOR
SUPPORT SERVICES INFLATION OF
SUPPORT COSTS. AS YOU KNOW
REVENUES ARE NO LONGER
SUFFICIENT. SEVERAL FACTORS
ALSO LIMIT THE ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL OF THE EXISTING
CASINO SUCH AS THE- CATION.
THROAT ONLY ACCESS TO THE- AND
THE LIMITED DEVELOP AREA TO
WATER SHE- ON THE REST OF. AND
THE- ITSELF. SB AC NINE WOULD.
THE COMPACT WHICH AMENDS THE
TRIBES TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
COMPACT IN ORDER TO FACILITATE.
THE RELOCATION OF THE EXISTING
CASINO. TO A TRAVELING OWN
FORTY ACRE PARCEL OF LAND.
LOCATED WITH THE TRIBES
ABORIGINAL TERRITORY IN THE
CITY F PORTER. REGARDING THE
RELOCATION SITE SECRETARY OF
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR ISSUED A POSITIVE
TERMINATION IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. REGARDING
GAMING ELIGIBILITY AT THE
RELOCATION SITE. THE TRIBES
APPLICATION TO PLACE THE
RELOCATION SITE IN THE TRUST.
AND THE GOVERNOR CONCURRED WITH
THE SECRETARY'S DETERMINATION
ON AUGUST THIRD OF TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY. THE TRIBE HAS A
LONG HISTORY AT THE RELOCATION
SITE IS FIVE MILES NORTH OF THE
TRIBES AND RATIFIED. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE TREATY TERRITORY AND
FIVE MILES SOUTHWEST OF THE
TRIBE'S ORIGINAL RESERVATION.
BOTH THE CITY AND THE STATE
HAVE RECOGNIZED THE TRYING TO
SPEAK THE MOST CLOSELY
CONNECTED. WITH HUMAN REMAINS
AND FUNERARY OBJECTS DISCOVERED.
NEAR THE RELOCATION SITE.
LIVING THE EXISTING TO THE-
SITE IS. TO INCREASE YOUR
RESERVATIONS FIVE BY
270-008-0060 GALLONS PER DAY.
ADDITIONALLY THE RELOCATION OF
EXISTING CASINO IS EXPECTED TO
NEARLY DOUBLE THE TRIBE'S
CAPTURING THE LOCAL GAMING
MARKET. REVENUE OF THE
OPERATION OF THE CASINO WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A VARIETY
OF HOUSING HEALTH EDUCATIONAL
SOCIAL CULTURAL AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. FOR THE
TRIBAL MEMBERS AND PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS. THE CASINO'S
RELOCATION ALSO ASSIST THE
COUNTY'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
WHICH AS OF MAY TWENTY TWENTY
WAS EIGHTEEN POINT FOUR
PERCENT. THE SIX HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AT THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
RELOCATION OF THE CASINOS
ESTIMATED TO CREATE TWELVE
HUNDRED TEMPORARY CONSTRUCTION
JOBS. AND A NET INCREASE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY PERMANENT
JOBS AND THE REGIONAL GAMING
MARKET CAN'T SUPPORT THE
CASINO'S RELOCATION. ALONG WITH
EXISTING IN. IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE RELOCATION OF THE
CASINO THE TRIBE AND THE CITY
WILL CONSTRUCT A WATER
RECLAMATION FACILITY ON CITY
OWNED PROPERTY. RECYCLED WATER
FROM THE RECLAMATION FACILITY
WILL REPLACE THE POSSIBLE WATER
CURRENTLY USED AT THE CITY
SPORTS COMPLEX. BECAUSE THE
PROJECT WILL USE LESS BOTTLE
WATER. THAN WHAT IS CURRENTLY
USED TO IRRIGATE THE SPORTS
COMPLEX THERE WILL BE A
730-008-0020 EIGHT GALLON PER
DAY INCREASE IN AVAILABLE
POTABLE WATER FOR THE SEAT. THE
TRIBE HAS THE SUPPORT THE
COUNTY AND THE CITY FOR THE
RELOCATION. OF THE CASINO AND
HAS ENTERED INTO MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH EACH. LASTLY
ON A PERSONAL NOTE. THIS IS
BEEN A LONG JOURNEY FOR OUR
TRIBE COMING FROM LIVING IN AND
DEBUNKED. RAM SHACKLE SHACKS TO
A QUALITY OF HOUSING THAT HAS
VASTLY IMPROVED OVER THE YEARS
SO I REALLY DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL TO PASS
AND I STEP FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
VERY COMPLETE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- TODAY- WE'RE
CIRCLING BACK DOWN TO- CHAIRMAN
IT THROUGH ALL I HAD DROUGHT-
ALLEN HAD REFERRED THE CHAIR OF
THE TASK INTO A BAND- CHAIRMAN
ARE YOU HERE ON THE LINE. I
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME WELCOME.
THANK YOU ARE ALIVE AND GROW ON
JURY CHAIRMAN OF THE PACKAGE A
BAND OF MEN LIKE INDIAN I'D
LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAYING. TO ME AFTER
TAKING THE TIME DURING YOU KNOW
THE YOUNG GOING PRACTICES
CLOSING SUBJECT. TRIBES IN
COMPACT. FOR STARTERS I'D LIKE
TO THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
THE NAME MARCH AND THE
GOVERNOR'S NEGOTIATING TEAM
QUARTER AFTER THE WORK COURTS
TO TRY TO CONTACT. ALSO I'D
LIKE TO THINK HUNDRED NIELSEN
WOMEN GALLAGHER ORDERING DURING
SUPPORT OF THE TRIED. IN
OBTAINING A NEW CONTRACT THAT
WILL FURTHER ENABLE THE TRIBE'S
ECONOMIC SELF RELIANCE AND
MAINTAIN ITS ABILITY TO BETTER
THE LIVES NOT ONLY TRIBAL
MEMBERS BUT CONNIE IN THE LIGHT
IN THE SURROUNDING AIM ACCOUNT
REACHING. BY VIRTUE OF THE
TRIBES NUMEROUS PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTIONS. THAT
COMES FROM THE GAMING OPERATION
THE GROWING OKAY YOU KNOW AND
THE TRIBES OTHER BUSINESSES.
I'VE RESPECTFULLY REFERRED CHIU
CHAIRMAN. HIS AUGUST SIXTH
TWENTY TWENTY LETTER WHICH WAS
CREATED WAS PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH THE TRIBES
INFORMATIONAL PREACHY. IT NASTY
WOULD LIKE TO CREATE THE TRIBES
LETTER INTO THE RECORD OR IF
YOU WOULD JUST PREFER. IT BE
MADE. BUT HEARING RECORD. WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT BE
A PART OF THE RECORD WILL MAKE
SURE THAT- WE GET A COPY OF
THAT AND SUBMITTED INTO THE
RECORD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ABSOLUTELY AND- I
ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK. CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE- FOR THEIR
EXPEDIENCE PROCESS OF SB EIGHT
SIXTY NINE AND WITH THAT. IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER. ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME I AM MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE- I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATOR
NIELSEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO TYPE IN
ON THIS PARTICULAR TRIBE WHO
ARE LITERALLY OUR NEIGHBORS. IN
TO HIM A COUNTY. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM FOR MANY MANY
YEARS MY WIFE AND I. WERE
FREQUENT VISITORS. BUT I'VE
PICKED A AWARE OF THE
GENEROSITY OF THIS TRIBE.
INCLUDING HELPING TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTH CARE IN THE AREA.
THEY HAVE A KIND OF A LANDMARK
SITE RUN ALONG INTERSTATE FIVE
THAT IS VERY VERY POPULAR. AND
THEY'VE HAD TO SUFFER LIKE ALL
TRIBES THROUGH THIS CORONAVIRUS
SITUATION. THEY MANAGE THEY
SURVIVE. ONE THING VERY SPECIAL
ABOUT THE SCANNER BAND THE
NUMBER LOCK INDIANS. IT'S
ALMOST EMOTIONAL WHEN I SPEAK
OF THIS BUT THEY HAD THEIR OWN
MANY MANY YEARS AGO TRIAL TRAIL
OF TEARS. THAT WAS A FAMOUS
STORY OF THOSE TERRIBLE TIMES
FOR THE INDIAN TRIBES WILL. THE
FIRST KIND OF BAND HAD THEIR
OWN. TRAIL OF TEARS. THEY DID
NOT LET THAT DETER THEM FROM.
PASSING ON THROUGH THEIR
GENERATION SINCE DRIVING. AND
PROSPERING IN THIS NEW SITE
THERE WELL SETTLED WELL
EXPERIENCED AT DEALING WITH THE
CONTACTS. THERE ARE TRIED THAT
KEEPS THEIR WORD. THEY ARE GOOD
NEIGHBORS. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANYBODY ELSE. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND GREAT CONGRATULATIONS
ON THE HARD WORK THANK YOU CAN
LOOK AT AND TAKE YOU MISTER
NIELSEN FOR YOUR KIND WORDS.
SHE OKAY WITH THAT- WE'RE GOING
TO NOW HEAR FROM JACK GRIFFIN
WHO I SHOULD BE ON THE
COASTLINE. MODERATOR YES I AM
PERFECT. YEAH OKAY THIS IS JACK
RENDON- I REPRESENT. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
UNITE HERE THE HOTEL AND CASINO
INDUSTRY- EIGHT THOUSAND OF
WHOM- WORK AS- TRIBAL CASINOS
ALTHOUGH THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE NOT WORKING AT THE
MOMENT FOR VERY OBVIOUS AND
TRAGIC REASONS- HOWEVER OUR
WHOLE. THAT THESE CONTACTS AND
OTHERS THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATED IN THE RECENT PAST
WILL BE GOOD WORK TOWARDS A
MAJOR RE OPENING AND A MAJOR
RECOVERY FOR THIS STATE OF THE
INDUSTRY. RIVAL GAMING- AND FOR
OUR MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO COME
BACK TO WORK SO AS A RESULT.
I'M HERE TO GIVE OUR SUPPORT TO
THE I. OWN BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS THE MORE TOWN RANCHERIA
OF MAY DO INDIANS THE PACKAGE
PRESIDENT OF BAND OF NAMA LAKI
INDIANS THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS THE
TOLOWA DEE NI NATION. AND THE
TULE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE-
THERE'S TWO. ISSUES THAT I
THINK THAT ARE IMPORTANT ONE IT
IS TOTALLY BETWEEN THE TRIBES
AND THE STATE BUT WE COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THAT OUR UNION DOES AND
THAT IS. THAT I THINK SHARE
WOMAN- QUAY ARE- SPOKE TO THIS
FACT DURING THE SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATION THERE WAS A BIG
EFFORT. TO FIND THE STATE
BUDGET THROUGH TRIBAL CASINOS
WHICH WE ALWAYS THOUGHT WAS.
WRONG FOR ALL OF THE HISTORICAL
REASONS THAT WE ALL KNOW AND WE
ARE VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE IN THE
FACT THAT BEGINNING WITH THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION NOW
CONTINUING. WITH THE NEWS
MINISTRATION THAT IS NO LONGER
THE CASE IN ADDITION WE ARE
ALSO VERY VERY. GRATEFUL FOR
THE PROTECTION OF THE FREEDOM
OF EXPRESSION AND THE FREEDOM
OF ASSOCIATION OF THE WORKERS
WHO WORK IN THESE CASINOS
THROUGH THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE BECAUSE OF
COURSE THEY ARE THE ENGINE.
BEHIND WHAT WAS IT TEN BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY AND IT'S OUR
HOPE IT WILL SOON BE A TEN
BILLIONDOLLAR INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA AGAIN- AND THANKS
VERY MUCH TO- ANNONAY MARK. AND
HER PROFESSIONALISM AND
WORKING- WITH EVERYONE INVOLVED
ACTUALLY TO REACH THESE
AGREEMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I MISS GRIFFIN ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING THAT IN THE
CHAMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IT'S AT THIS
POINT TIME THAT WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. COULD
WE- SEE IF THERE'S THIS ANYBODY
HERE IN THE GALLERY I'M NOT SEE
ANYBODY WANTS TO THE TESTIMONY
AND HOW BOUT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING THAT NOW WILL MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WAITING TO THE TEST OF
THE- THE- TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU'D PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
WE WILL BEGIN. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF ELECTED
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE THAT ARE
PERTINENT TO ONE OPERATOR.
WELCOME MY NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- PAUL YOU'RE ON BEHALF
OF THE TO BE CONTACT IN THE
TULARE CONTACT ON BEHALF OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR NEXT LINE.
OPERATOR HOW MANY IN Q. WE HAVE
THREE ADDITIONAL PARTICIPANTS
ONLINE THANK YOU. MY PLEASURE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN DODD AND RESPECTED
MEMBERS THIS IS MARTHA FOR AS I
AM THE MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF
PORTER BILL AND TULARE COUNTY I
WISH TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY TO THE CONTACT BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE TO
THE RIVER TRIED THE CITY AND
THE TO THE RIVER TRIED HAVE AND
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP BASED ON
MUTUAL RESPECT AND COOPERATION
AND SUCCESSFULLY DEVELOP
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
THAT IS OF MUTUAL BENEFIT TO
BOTH PARTIES BUT CITY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE COMPACT AND THE
PROPOSED PROJECT NOT ONLY FOR
ITS STRONG PROMOTION OF THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO
FOR THE IMPROVE COMMUNITY
SERVICES THIS PROJECT WILL
CREATE NEW FULL AND PART TIME
JOBS AS WELL AS MANY OTHER
INDIRECT JOBS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE QUARTER BILL COMMUNITY IN
ADDITION THIS PROJECT WILL HAVE
A NET ZERO IMPACT TO THE CITY'S
WATER SYSTEM. AND THE WATER
TABLE THROUGH A JOINT
DEVELOPMENT OF A RECYCLED WATER
FACILITY THIS CALL FUNDED
FACILITY WILL BETTER SERVE THE
CITY'S RESIDENTS AND SUPPORT
THE FUTURE DEVELOPMENT IN
PORTERVILLE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
CITY'S PERSPECTIVE AT THE PORT
FOR THIS PROJECT THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPROVE SERVICES TO THE
RESIDENTS ARE AVAIL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH. TWENTY TWO YEAR LINE
IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ROMAN STATUS
ON THE BEHALF OF THE UNITED
AUBURN INDIAN COMMUNITY TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TO THE
RIVER TRIBES AMENDED COMPACT
I'D LIKE TO FIRST THANK
GOVERNOR THIS DAY MARK. FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE THIS
THIS COMPACT AND I HAVE TO DO
THE- TRONG WE NOTICE LEADERSHIP
OF CHAIRMAN NEIL PERONE AND BY
SHERMAN GARFIELD. AND MOVING
THIS FORWARD THANK YOU. TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THAT THE TELLER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR KYLE CROCKER AND I'D
LIKE TO ECHO SOME OF MAYOR
AS CHAIRMAN HER OWN- THE CLERK
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISOR
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE TO LOOK
TO THE RIVER DR DEFORD. ONLY
WITH THIS EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ONE OF THE
POOREST COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
BUT IT WOULD ALSO INCREASE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS. THE
WATER TREATMENT PLANT HELP WITH
OUR LOCAL LAW NEEDS IN AN AREA
THAT INCLUDES THE INFAMOUS.
EAST PORTABLE THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SURE DODD MEMBERS
OF THE NY THIS IS CRITICALLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WE DON'T HAVE OFFICIAL
POSITIONS ON ANY OF THE COMPACT
DISCUSS THIS MORNING BUT WE
WANTED TO THANK THE TRY THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS NAMEMARK FOR
INCLUDING PROVISIONS THAT
ENSURE THE MITIGATION OF OFF
RESERVATION IMPACTS OF TRIBAL
GAMING. WE THINK THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
IN PROMOTING POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TRIBES IN
COUNTY AND ENSURING THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICES
THAT WE ALL RELY ON ITS
SUSPICIONS. THANK YOU. TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUSAN JENSEN
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THESE
CONTACTS- THEY ARE UNIQUE TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL TRIED- AND- WE
WISH THEM GREAT LOCKS. BEFORE
WE OPEN LINE NINETEEN I LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYONE IF YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO OUT OF
TIME. ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MR NOVEMBER'S PLAYER
AGAIN I REALLY APOLOGIZE I
EARLIER SAID. BUTTE COUNTY AND
I MEANT DEAL NOR COUNTY SANTA
IS AND THAT BORDERS THEIR FULL
SUPPORT OF ITS- RESPECTIVE
CONTACT THANK YOU. HELLO AND IF
YOU LIKE TO. ACCUSE ME IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT AN TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO
PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT HE
MADE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
ONE PUBLIC COMMENT. WELL DONE
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR HARD
WORK TODAY- LET ME- PERSONALLY
THANK GOODNESS NAY MARK FOR ALL
HER WORK ON THESE CONTACTS. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
TRIBAL CHAIRS IN MISTER GRIFFIN
FOR THEIR COMMENTS OF BEING
EXTREMELY FLEXIBLE DURING THESE
INCREDIBLY TOUGH TIMES. ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS IS A JERK. ALL.